GOOD AFTERNOON ALL CALL THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
OF ENTITLED PROMOTING MENTAL
HEALTH WELLNESS FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO ORDER --
WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION SEPARATION HEARING ON
MENTAL WELLNESS FOR ALL STUDENTS --
WE KNOW THAT TOO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING FROM
TRAUMA DEPRESSION ANXIETY AND
OTHER BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ISSUES.
AND ARE NOT RECEIVING THE
NECESSARY SUPPORT [inaudible]
AND TREATMENT.
THIS ISSUE WAS HIGHLIGHTED
DURING LAST WEEK'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS OF RECENT WHILE FIGHTERS
AND SUBSEQUENT EVENTS ON
STUDENTS AND THE ON GOING NEED.
FOR SUPPORT BEYOND THE IMMEDIATE
[inaudible]
DISASTER.
THE IMPACTS OF TRAUMA AFFECTS
STUDENTS ABILITY TO SUCCEED
ACADEMICALLY AS WELL AS OUR
OVERALL HEALTH.
AND WELL BEING AND CERTAINLY
THEIR ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL HIGHLIGHT
THE SCOPE OF THIS NEED AND
DISCUSS WAYS THAT SCHOOLS AND
COUNTIES CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
EXCESS AVAILABLE FUNDING. TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO REALLY HAVE
THAT CONVERSATION TODAY AND
BEYOND FOR SURE ABOUT HOW
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES.
CAN WORK TOGETHER.
I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE JOINING ME
TODAY I THINK.
RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST MISTER KILEY
THE THE END OF THIS COMMITTEE
WAS A THEY PURCHASE OF YOU YOU
BROUGHT THIS TOPIC TO ME AND
SAID HEY WE NEED.
TO WE NEED TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION SO I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN.
ALONG THOSE LINES AND I THINK
MISTER KILEY MAY WISH TO MAKE
SOME OPENING REMARKS.
I YES THANKS VERY MUCH AND ONE
TO THANK CATCH CHAIR O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
WE GET.
I THANK CHAIRMAN DON ALL OUT AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER WILL HER WITH
ME TO PUT TOGETHER THIS HEARING
AROUND VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
FACING THAT OUR STUDENTS AND AND
OUR SCHOOLS.
YOU KNOW IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THAT TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
PARENTS ABOUT MY DISTRICT ONE
TOPIC THAT CONSISTENTLY ARISES
AS AN AREA OF NEED IS MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND STUDENT WELLNESS IN OUR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM.
A REVIEW OF THE RESEARCH ON THE
TOPIC ALSO THE PROBLEM HAS
BECOME SO CUTE YOUTH SUICIDE
RATES ARE RISING NEARLY EVERY
YEAR IN CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE NOW AT THEIR HIGHEST
LEVELS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX
THAT SEVEN POINT NINE SUICIDES
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
AGES FIFTEEN THROUGH.
TWENTY FOUR IN RURAL CALIFORNIA
OR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
MOST LIMITED THE SUICIDE RATE IS
OFTEN TRIPLE.
THE STATE AVERAGE.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST RECENT HEALTHY
KIDS SURVEY.
FOUND THAT 34% OF ELEVENTH
GRADERS EXPERIENCE CHRONIC SINUS
AND 16%.
HAVE SERIOUSLY CONTEMPLATED
SUICIDE.
AND THE STATISTICS DON'T EVEN
INCLUDE STUDENTS RECOVERING FROM
TRAUMA THEY EXPERIENCED IN OUR
RECENT WILDFIRES AS A CHAIR
O'DONNELL MENTIONED.
NOW WHETHER NUMEROUS FACTORS
CONTRIBUTING TO THESE TRENDS.
IT'S HARD TO DENY THE
PERVASIVENESS OF SOCIAL MEDIA
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO INCREASES.
IN CYBER BOWLING BOWLING.
UNFORTUNATELY IT CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT APPEAR TO BE PREPARED TO
RESPOND TO THESE ALARMING
FRIENDS.
ACCORDING TO STANFORD
UNIVERSITY'S MOST RECENT GETTING
DOWN TO FAX REEF ON MENTAL
HEALTH IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS
CALIFORNIA RANKS AT OR NEAR THE
BOTTOM NATIONALLY. FOR STUDENT
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
WELL I BELIEVE THIS ISSUE MAY
REQUIRE ACTION OF THE PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE I WANTED TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY. TO HELP
US DETERMINE THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM AND DISCUSS THE BEST
COURSE OF ACTION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS
THAT CAME BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE.
LAST YEAR --
THAT WERE WELL MEANING --
OF THAT PRESS THE ISSUE FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES REQUIRING --
CERTAIN NUMBERS OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WITHIN DISTRICTS
WITHIN SCHOOLS --
BUT I YEAH I WANTED TO HAVE THIS
HEARING IN PART TO SEE WHAT
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS ARE
ALREADY DOING BECAUSE THERE'S A
LOT OF GREAT THAT GREAT THINGS
BEING DONE AT SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND WE COULD THEN GET
A BETTER SENSE.
OF WHAT WORKS WHAT'S BEING DONE
WELL WHAT'S ACTUALLY I HAVE AN
IMPACT IN REACHING STUDENTS WHO
ARE IN NEED AND WE CAN USE THAT
AS A BASIS TO GUIDE POLICY
MAKING GOING FORWARD.
I'M ALSO SPECIFICALLY INTERESTED
IN LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT LOCAL EDUCATION --
AGENCIES AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FACE WHEN IT COMES TO ACCESSING
FUNDING AND WORKING WITH
COUNTIES TO SERVE STUDENTS.
IS THE SOLUTION TO SIMPLY
PROVIDE ELEAZAR WITH MORE
INFORMATION INCREASE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN COUNTIES
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
OR STRUCTURAL BARRIERS EXIST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN ASSIST
IN BREAKING THROUGH I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF THE PARTICIPANTS
FOR BEING HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS.
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I
ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK THE
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT FOR
COMING TO SHARE YOUR EXPERIENCES
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
DISCUSSION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MY COLLEAGUES ON ADDRESSING
THESE PROBLEMS TO ENSURE THAT
OUR STUDENTS ENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLNESS NEEDS ARE BEING MET
THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY OF MISS
WITH THE JEWISH TO COMMENT --
I JUST WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TODAY AS I'VE TOWARD
MY DISTRICT AND HAVE NOW MET
WITH ALL OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS
I INVOLVED IN OUR LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RESOUNDINGLY.
THE ISSUE OF SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
WELL BEING OF OUR STUDENTS --
IS PARAMOUNT TO THEM AND HOW WE
FUND THESE PROGRAMS AND BEGIN TO
COORDINATE SYSTEMS OF OF CARE
AND COVERAGE IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT SOME FIVE OR DOING
THIS.
THANK YOU --
WILL TURN OUR FIRST PANEL OUR
FIRST PANEL ON MENTAL HEALTH
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND INVITE
OUR TWO SPEAKERS TO COME FORWARD.
AND THERE ALLEN ALEX BRISCOE
ALEX BRISCOE.
YOU MAY COME FORWARD THANK YOU.
AND YOU MAY PROCEED ONE RIGHT
[inaudible]
AFTERNOON [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
ASIDE LIKE TO BEGIN BY I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THIS
TOPIC -- I'M
GONNA IN TWELVE MINUTES OR LESS --
REAFFIRM TO YOU THAT THE CRISIS
IS REAL THROUGH SOME DATA THAT'S
VERY SPECIFIC TO CALIFORNIA.
THANK NOT TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A SUCCESSFUL EXAMPLE.
WHERE ONE COUNTY AND A SERIES OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ADDED TEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN TO CARE OVERS
OVER TEN YEAR PERIOD?
AND CREATED UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE AND TO FIND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE SUCCESS.
BUT THEN I'LL ANSWER THE DIRECT
QUESTION THAT THE MEMBER JUST
BEFORE YES THE CHALLENGES ARE
STRUCTURAL AND WE WILL NEED
ACTION. TO CREATE A MUCH BROADER.
ACCESS TO CARE FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH.
SO --
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF DREAMING
IN THIS NEXT TWELVE MINUTES AND
THEN THERE'S A LOT OF DEEP
MEDICAID FINANCE.
BUT AT THE HEART OF THIS CHILD
OF THIS NARRATIVE THAT I'M GONNA
GIVE YOU IS THINK A LITTLE BIT
LIKE PEANUT BUTTER PEANUT BUTTER
AND CHOCOLATE.
THE NEXUS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUBLIC EDUCATION IS RIGHT AND
GOOD AND REAL.
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE
PUTTING BEFORE OUR LOCAL CHILD
SERVING SEEKING THAT'S ARE TOO
SIGNIFICAN TO BE OVERCOME.
GIVEN THE CURRENT RESOURCES
AVAILABLE.
AND BY WAY OF LEGITIMATION.
I BEGAN MY CAREER.
AS A THERAPIST IN THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I WORKED AS AN EMERGENCY ROOM
SOCIAL WORKER CHILDREN'S OAKLAND.
AND THEN I LET ONE OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST CHILDREN'S
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEMS AS THE
HEALTH DIRECTOR NAMI TO COUNTY
FOR ABOUT SEVEN YEARS.
SO YOU CAN'T NAME A MEDICAID
REVENUE STREAM THAT I HAVEN'T
BUILT.
I PERSONALLY BILLS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS DE PST
MEDICARE MEDICAID.
I'VE RUN AFTER HE SEES I'VE
WORKED IN HOSPITALS I STARTED --
SEKHEMRE CHEESE PORTIONS OF A
HOME CHILD WELFARE SO WHAT I'M
GONNA AMOUNT OF TIME BUT ANY OF
THAT BUT I HOPE YOU CAN FEEL
BEHIND THE SLIDES ABOUT TO SHOW
YOU.
A LOTOF EXPERIENCE WITH PUBLIC
I'M INTERESTING.
DOING STUFF THAT.
SO I AS QUICK EVIDENCE OF THE
CRISIS I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE DATA
THAT WAS PUT FORWARD IN YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS --
BUT IT'S REAL SOMETHING'S
HAPPENING WITH KIDS WERE NOT
MAKING IT UP THERE'S BEEN A 50%
INCREASE IN HOSPITAL DAYS FOR
TERMS NOT HEALTH BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND SIX IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN NOW WHY
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT IS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE HEALTH CARE SPECTRUM
LENGTH OF STAY MEANING DAYS
SPENT IN THE HOSPITAL.
ACROSS ALL DISEASE BURDENS HAS
DECREASED BY ABOUT 30%.
ONLY IN ONE AREA HAS INCREASED.
TURNS ON HEALTH.
AND THE THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE INITIALLY ABOUT A SUICIDE
SUICIDE IN THE LAST DECADE.
HAS LEAPFROGGED CANCER AND CAR
WRECKS AS A CAUSE OF DEATH.
SO GRATEFUL HERE THE DETAIL --
NEVER MIND ABOUT AT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SWISS
ACADEMIC.
HE'S EPIDEMIOLOGICAL CHANGES ARE
MASSIVE.
AND THEY'RE GOING UNDER REPORTED.
ON NAMES WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF
USE NOT A HEALTH CRISIS BY ANY
STANDARD MEASUREMENT.
I SELF INJURY JUST DEFINED BY
CUTTING SELF MUTILATION SUICIDE
ATTEMPTS TWO SENATE TEMPTED SELF
INJURY IS UP OVER A 100%.
AND WE'RE SPENDING OVER ELEVEN
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
THE HARSH HARD REALITY IS THAT
MOST CHILDREN IN OUR SYSTEM GET
NO SUPPORT AND THOSE WHO DO GET
IT.
GET THE WRONG KIND TOO LATE.
OUR CURRENT MODEL SAYS THAT YOU
HAVE TO MEET WHAT WE CALL
MEDICAL DEBT A NEST NECESSITY TO
GET ACCESS TO CARE ENOUGH TO
HAVE A DIAGNOSIS.
BUT IF YOU GO BACK TO THE
ORIGINS OF THE MEDICAID MANDATE
FOR MENTAL HEALTH.
GIVE TO GO BACK TO NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN IN THE SOCIAL
SECURITY ACT.
AS A QUICK HISTORY LESSON.
IN 196740% OF THE YOUNG MEN WHO
SHOWED UP FOR THE VIETNAM DRAFT.
WERE UNFIT TO SERVE COULD MAKE
IT AROUND THE TRACK COULDN'T GET
OVER A FOOT BARRIER.
THUS WAS BORN ONE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST SUCCESSFUL
EXPERIMENTS IN PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS CALL THE T. P. STT MANDATE
AND WHAT IS SAID IS THAT ALL
CHILDREN IN MEDICAID.
GET EVERYTHING THEY NEED TO
THRIVE.
AND YOU KNOW IT BECAUSE THE
MUSICIANS. 90% OF LOW INCOME
CHILDREN GET THEIR MUSIC BUT
WHAT WE DON'T WE ALSO KNOW ABOUT
MEDICAID OR MENTAL HEALTH IS
THAT ONLY 4% OF CHILDREN GET A
MEDICAL SERVICE.
THE BARRIERS TO GETTING ACCESS
TO CARE ARE LARGELY BECAUSE OF
THESE ISSUES REGARDING MEDICAL
NECESSITY WE REQUIRE CHILDREN TO
MEET IN ON A REASONABLE STANDARD.
TO GET ACCESS TO OUR SYSTEM THEY
HAVE TO FILL INTO IT TO GET
ACCESS TO CARE.
SO SINCE TWENTY ELEVEN THERE'S
BEEN A 20% INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF CHILDREN IN MEDICAID ANOTHER
POORLY UNDERSTOOD THING. THREE
MAJOR POLICY DRIVERS LED TO THIS
20% INCREASE.
THE INCLUSION OF THE
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FULL
SCOPE MEDICAID SB.
SEVENTY FIVE THE ROMAN
ELIGIBILITY EFFORTS OF THE ACA
WE BROUGHT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
WERE PREVIOUSLY ELIGIBLE OUT.
AND THE RULING IN THE VESTIAN.
MEANING THAT NOW ALL CHILDREN
UNDER 2100% OF CHILDREN 50% OF
OUR PARTY QUALIFY FOR MEDICAID.
SO JUST THINK FOR SECOND THAT'S
OVER SIX MILLION OF CALIFORNIA'S
TEN MILLION CHILDREN.
ARE FEDERALLY ENTITLED. TO ALL
THE SERVICES THEY NEED TO
PREVENT HARM.
ONLY 4% ARE GETTING ON OUR
CURRENT MEDICAID THE WHOLE
SYSTEM --
THAT'S AT LAST BLUEPRINT THE
BOTTOM -- SO
THIS DATA JUST QUICKLY SHOWS YOU
THAT THE SAME BENEFIT THAT
COVERS ACCIDENTS RIGHT THAT SAME
NUMBER I GAVE YOU 90% OF KIDS
GET THEIR AMOUNT AND I'M IN OUR
SHUTTLE TIME.
THE ONLY 4% OF GETTING MANY
OTHER MEDICAID NOW SERVICE.
OUR SYSTEM BY ANY STANDARD
MEASURES BROKEN.
AND WE CAN'T DO IT THROUGH
HOSPITALS.
OR THROUGH CLINICS THAT'S WHY I
SAY THE MEDICAL MODEL IS NOT THE
ANSWER. 75% OF MENTAL ILLNESS
MANIFESTS BETWEEN FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR BUT FOURTEEN AND
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLDS HAVE THE
LOWEST RATE OF HEALTH CARE
UTILIZATION OF ANY
DEMOGRAPHICALLY.
SOME TALKING US INTO WHY SCHOOLS
ARE SO ESSENTIAL.
SCHOOLS ARE THE CLINIC OF THE
FUTURE FOR TEENS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HURTS
YOUNG PEOPLE THEIR MOBILITY
FACTORS WHAT TAKES THEM TO THE
HOSPITAL IT'S ALMOST ALL
BEHAVIORAL IN NATURE?
LOCAL YOUNG PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY.
WHAT THEY NEED IS BEHAVIORAL
SUPPORT AND THE PLACE TO GET IT
TO HIM IS SCHOOLS --
THE REST OF THE DAY ON THE SLIDE
JUST SHOWS YOU THE PROVIDER
SHORTAGE CHALLENGES WE HAVE YOU
CAN'T DO IT THROUGH TRADITIONAL
MEDICAL MODELS.
SCHOOLS ARE PERFECT PLACE TO
DELIVER THE SERVICES.
AS A QUICK EXAMPLE WHILE I WAS
THE HEALTH DIRECTOR ON THE
ACCOUNTING WE DID ONE OF THE
MOST THE LARGEST EXPANSIONS OF
CHILDREN AND HEALTH IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY --
WE'RE ABOUT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE FOR FOR FOURTEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FIVE SELFLESS.
AND JUST A QUICKLY TAKE YOU
THROUGH THIS EXPANSION.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND
ONE WE HAD ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
KIDS IN OUR SYSTEM WEAK CHRIS --
TO TO FOURTEEN THOUSAND I'M
ABOUT TO TELL THE STORY NOT TO
SUGGEST IT'S A BLUEPRINT FOR THE
FUTURE BECAUSE WE HAD SOME
THINGS ALAMEDA COUNTY THAT MOST
COUNTIES DO NOT HAVE.
PROVIDER BASE IN A GROUP OF
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
READY WILLING AND COMPETENT TO
SERVE.
WE HAD A PROGRESSIVE BOARD
SUPERVISORS WHO HAD ACCESS TO
ASSESSMENT REVENUE LOCAL SALES
TAX ON TOBACCO REVENUE SO THINGS
THAT MOST COUNTIES DON'T HAVE.
BUT I'M I WANT TO TELL THE STORY
BECAUSE IT CAN BE DONE WITH WILL
AND RESOURCES MOST COUNTIES
DON'T HAPPEN THOUGH.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX WE HAD
FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
IN TWO THOUSAND WE HAD EIGHT IN
TWO THOUSAND FOR WE HAVE TWELVE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE HAVE.
FOURTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WE
HAVE NINETEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE WE HAD TWENTY SIX IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WE HAD TWENTY
NINE AND CAN CURRENTLY WE OPENED
TWO HUNDRED SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH PROGRAMS.
IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE CREATED THE FIRST
MAJOR URBAN SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH
UNIVERSAL ACCESS TO PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL HEALTH ON EVERY MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUS.
THERE'S A CLINICIAN IN EVERY
SCHOOL.
AGAIN THIS IS NOT NECESSARILY
THE BLUEPRINT BECAUSE WHAT WE
ADDED THOSE TEN THOUSAND
CHILDREN TO CARE WE REQUIRED
EACH ONE OF THEM HAD A DIAGNOSIS
TO GET ACCESS TO CARE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU HAVING
REPRESENTED A VERY SMALL CHUNK
OF THOSE TEN THOUSAND CHILDREN.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE KIDS I
SERVE WE'RE NOT PATHOLOGICAL.
THE REGION WITH ADVERSITY.
THEY'RE DOING WITH THE
CHALLENGES OF GROWING UP.
SO WE NEED TO RE WORK OUR SYSTEM
SO MORE KIDS ARE QUALIFIED
INELIGIBLE.
AND ENSURE THE RESOURCES IN
FINANCING ARE AVAILABLE AT
LARGELY AT SCHOOL SETTINGS.
OF THOSE TEN THOUSAND CHILDREN
WE ADDED TO CARE OUR SYSTEM
THROUGH SCHOOLS.
SO JUST TO CLOSE WHERE I THINK
THE REFORM SYSTEM NEEDS TO GO
ALSO TO GIVE ACCESS TO THE TYPE
OF DOLLARS AND EXPERTISE THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED WE NEED TO
MAKE SOME FUNDAMENTAL REFORMS.
TO OUR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM
AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT'S WHY I
ASK FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT.
THE FIRST WE HAVE TO MAXIMIZE
FEDERAL LEVEL FEDERAL REVENUE.
CALIFORNIA RANKS FORTY EIGHT IN
THE NATION AND SPENDING FOR
MEDICAID BENEFICIARY.
A SET ONE MORE TIME CALIFORNIA
RANKS FORTY EIGHT IN THE NATION
AND SPENDING.
THE FIN FIN YEAR OF
PROGRESSIVENESS OF OUR STATE
EVAPORATES QUICKLY WHEN YOU LOOK
AT WHAT KIDS ACTUALLY GET.
SO WE NEED TO BRING IN NEW
FEDERAL REVENUE.
THROUGH SOMETHING CALLED A STATE
PLAN AMENDMENT I WON'T GO INTO
DETAILS HERE BUT CLEARLY
MAXIMIZING FEDERATION IS
ESSENTIAL THE STATE CAN'T FOR
THE BILL.
WE HAVE TO BROADEN ACCESS TO
SERVICES MEANING WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THE THINGS WE DO AS
BEYOND JUST A FIFTY MINUTE
THERAPEUTIC SESSION.
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF HERE'S WHAT
ARE THE ROLES OF PARA PARTNERS
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF EXTENDERS OR
NON TRADITIONAL PROVIDERS OF
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SUPPORTS?
THE TRADITIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM HAS A LOT TO LEARN FROM
THE RECOVERY COMMUNITY.
TONIGHT MILLIONS OF PEOPLE GET
TOGETHER BOUND ONLY BY THE
COMMON EXPERIENCE OF SUFFERING.
WHERE IS THE SOCIAL MODEL FOR
BEING YOUNG AND BROWN IN OAKLAND
FOR BEING A NEW MOTHER FOR BEING
A RECENT IMMIGRANT?
WE NEED TO THINK OF OUR MEDICAL
SYSTEM IS BEYOND JUST A CLINICAL
SUPPORT BUT AS A BROAD SOCIAL
MOVEMENT TO BUILD SOCIAL CAPITAL.
AND FINALLY HAVE TO PURCHASE HOW
WE PAY.
AS THE HEALTH DIRECTOR SAT ON
THE BOARD OF HEALTH PLAN.
WE SERVE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS.
WE HAD EIGHT FINANCE STUFF.
THE MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
THAT I AM HELPED A MINISTER OR
LEAD.
WE SERVE A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WE HAD A HUNDRED FINANCE
STUFF.
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THAT
COUNTIES ARE BEING ASKED TO BEAR.
TO ADMINISTER THESE DOLLARS IS
SO MUCH GREATER ON THE BEHAVIOR
OUTSIDE THAT IS ON THE PHYSICAL
HEALTH SIDE WE HAVE TO CHANGE
HOW DOLLARS FLOW FROM THE STATE.
TO COUNTIES TO MAKE IT MORE
STREAMLINED AND TO EXPAND ACCESS
TO REVENUE.
AND I KNOW THAT SOUNDS HUGE BUT
THAT'S THE WAY SCHOOLS WILL GET
WHAT THEY NEED.
IS BY TRANSFORMING HOW THE STATE
ADMINISTERS ITS MEDICAID PROGRAM.
SO MY LAST SLIDE IS WE HAVE NEW
SCIENCE AND EMERGING PRACTICES.
SO TOUCH ANYTHING BUT HARRIS IS
JOINING THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
STATE WE ARE NOW UNDERSTANDING
THE IMPACT OF ADVERSITY ON
HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
WHY ISN'T ADVERSITY THE
TRIGGERING ABOUT FROM A WHOLE
SERVICE NOT PATHOLOGY?
RIGHT BUT TOUGH THINGS HAPPEN TO
YOU IF YOU NEED SUPPORT.
THEY'RE STRIKING EVIDENCE OF A
CRISIS YOU ALREADY KNEW IT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DATA.
THERE IS AN ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE
WE HAVE DRAMATIC INCREASING%
COSTS IN THE MEDICAID PROGRAM
FOR CHILDREN A MENTAL HEALTH.
AND I BELIEVE THERE'S A WAY TO
FINANCE REFORM BY CLEANING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL REVENUE ON
WHAT THE STATUS ARE SPENDING.
I'LL START MY COMMENTS --
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MY NAME
IS TOBY EWING I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION I TOO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THIS ON AND TO HER KILEY
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE LAST YEAR
TO WORK WITH YOU.
ON SOME LEGISLATION AROUND
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
WERE AND WHERE STATE AGENCY WERE
AN INDEPENDENT BODY IN SOME WAYS
WORK INTO SORT OF A MENTAL
HEALTH GRAND JURY FOR THE STATE.
WE'VE GIVEN YOU SOME WRITTEN
TESTIMONY AND SOME EXAMPLES OF
SOME OF THE THINGS WE HAVE UNDER
WAY.
I I WOULD AGREE WITH MISTER
BRISCOE THAT THE CRISIS IS VERY
REAL AND AND WE SEE THIS ARE
COMMISSIONER SEE THIS.
IN ONE OF THE MOST OF THE
GLARING EXAMPLES HIS CHILDREN AS
YOUNG AS KINDERGARTEN TALKING
ABOUT SUICIDE WHEN I WHEN I WAS
GROWING UP I DON'T RECALL THAT
HAPPENING.
THAT JUST SO SHOCKING TO MY
CONSCIENCE TALKING WITH TEACHERS
AND PRINCIPALS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS.
WE GET PHONE CALLS EMAILS
LETTERS PEOPLE APPROACH US IN
COMMUNITY FORUMS AND TALK ABOUT.
THE MISSED OPPORTUNITIES HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO ACCESS
SERVICES WE SEE THESE CHALLENGES
IN TEACHERS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING TO HELP STUDENTS
ACADEMICALLY WHEN THEIR NEEDS
WHAT'S GETTING IN THE WAY OF
THEIR ACADEMICS ARE NOT ACADEMIC
ISSUES.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WE HEAR
FROM TEACHERS WHO WANT TO
RESPOND BUT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW.
WE DON'T THEY DON'T HAVE THE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE FOR THE
STRATEGIES IN PLACE.
QUITE OFTEN WE GET ASK WELL
HOW'S CALIFORNIA DOING IN THIS
REGARD AND I AND I WOULD I
ALWAYS START OFF WITH A LITTLE
BIT OF HOPE.
THE MIDDLE HOW SERVICES ACT HAS
A COUPLE OF COMPONENTS HERE THAT
ARE VERY EXPLICIT.
UNDER A PREVENTION STATEMENT IN
THE MAIL HOW SERVICES ACT THAT
INCLUDES A STATEMENT ABOUT
REDUCING SCHOOL FAILURE.
THE STATE RECEIVES BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY AND FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE GOING
TOWARDS PREVENTION KINDS OF
ACTIVITIES.
THAT SAYS PREVENTING SCHOOL
FAILURE IS ONE OF OUR CLEAR
GOALS.
WE ALSO HAVE LANGUAGE IN THE LAW
THAT SAYS COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED
TO BE INNOVATIVE AND YOU'VE
HEARD A LOT I THINK IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS ABOUT HOW.
COUNTIES ARE ARE OR ARE NOT
SPENDING FUNDS EITHER IN THEIR
PREVENTION SIDE OF THE
RENOVATION SIDE.
THE REAL ISSUE HERE I THINK IS
THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE CAN BEGIN TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
MISTER BRISCOE HAS HIGHLIGHTED.
WE ALSO HAVE HOPE IN THAT WE
HAVE PARTNERSHIPS ACROSS THE
STATE IT ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE YOU'RE GONNA HEAR LATER
TODAY FROM AMY MILLER FROM
MONTEREY COUNTY WE WERE ABLE TO
VISIT SOME OF HER PROGRAMS.
WE'RE SEEING PROGRAMS IN
MONTEREY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN THE BAY AREA THAT ARE SHOWING
TREMENDOUS PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN
SCHOOLS.
AND THEY'RE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
PARTNERS FRESNO IS RECENTLY
INVESTING IN AT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS DOING.
BUT WE SEE SOME FUNDAMENTAL
CHALLENGES AND WE WE SEE THAT
QUITE OFTEN THE EXAMPLES OF THE
ALAMEDA OR THE MONORAIL OR
SALMON YOU KNOW RIVERSIDE.
OFTEN ARE WORKING UPSTREAM THE
STATE MAKES IT OFTEN VERY
DIFFICULT I I THINK YOU'LL HEAR
FROM.
DOCTOR MILLER AROUND THE
CHALLENGES THE WRIST THAT SHE
TAKES IN TRYING TO DESIGN A
STRATEGY THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN HER
SCHOOLS.
WHAT?
WE ARE DOING A NUMBER OF THINGS
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CREATE AND THERE'S I
THINK WE'VE GIVEN YOU A LIST OF
SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
WERE WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SIR EDUCATION TO SEE
IF WE COULD LINK EDUCATION DATA
AND MENTAL HEALTH DATA TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S IN PLACE TODAY
UNDERSTAND HOW.
ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
IS SUPPORTING EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES WE'RE TRYING TO BUILD
LEARNING COLLABORATIVE'S ACROSS
COUNTIES WHEN WE TALKED COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS. ONE
OF THE NUMBER ONE THING STILL
TELL US IS THEY HAVE A VERY HARD
TIME FINDING OUT WHAT EVERYBODY
ELSE IS DOING.
IN A VERY HARD TIME FINDING OUT
HOW TO DO THE THINGS THAT THEY
WANT TO GET DONE SO EVEN WHEN WE
HAVE LEADERSHIP AND SOME OF
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT WANT TO
TACKLE THESE ISSUES.
IT FEELS OVERWHELMING.
PART OF THAT FOR THE FOR THE
COMMISSION IS WE'RE WE'RE
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS AND I'VE OUTLINED
SOME OF THAT IN MY TESTIMONY.
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES WE SEE IS
MENTAL HEALTH IN SCHOOLS FALLS
BETWEEN SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONAL DESIGN THAT WE
HAVE IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
HAVE THE PART OF EDUCATION THEY
HAVE A ROLE WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT HEALTH CARE SERVICES
THEY HAVE A ROLE THE COMMISSION
HAS A ROLE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS A ROLE.
THE OFFICE OF HEALTH INFORMATION
INTEGRITY HAS A ROLE IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THE LEGAL --
BARRIERS THAT GET IN THE WAY OF
OF INFORMATION SHARING AND
COLLABORATION ACROSS THIS
COUNTIES ORGANIZATIONALLY.
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE STATE BE
THAT CHAMPION TO HELP COUNTIES
UNDERSTAND WITH THEIR SCHOOL
PARTNERS WHAT THEY CAN DO HOW TO
DO IT AND AND IN WAYS THAT ARE
COST EFFECTIVE RIDE.
THIS THIS SOME OF THE COMMENTS
THAT WE'LL HEAR FROM DIRECTORS
YOU'LL HEAR LATER SAY I HOPE
ABOUT HAVING TO SWIM UPSTREAM.
IT CAN BE TWICE AS DIFFICULT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING IN THE SYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE AND I THINK THAT'S
ONE OF THE MESSAGES AT LEAST I
HERE.
IN MISTER BRISCOE'S TESTIMONY.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEVERAGE THE TRUST AND
RESPECT THAT FAMILIES HAVE FOR
THEIR SCHOOLS PARTICULARLY
TEACHERS.
WHEN WE TALK WITH CONSUMERS AND
FAMILY MEMBERS QUITE OFTEN THAT
TRUST BECAUSE OF STIGMA ISN'T
THERE WITH THE MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM?
IN SOME CASES A VERY CLEARLY YES
BUT WE'VE HEARD FROM FAMILIES
WHO SAID I'D BE HAPPY TO GO TO
MY SCHOOL TO ACCESS SERVICES I'D
BE HAPPY TO ASK MY NEIGHBOR TO
GIVE ME A RIDE THIS IS AN ACTUAL
STORY FROM MONTEREY.
HAVE A FAMILY THAT DIDN'T HAVE A
CAR THAT WAS RECEIVING SERVICES
TO THE SCHOOL AND THEY'RE ABOUT
TO SAY COULD YOU GIVE MY MYSELF
AND MY CHILD THE RIGHT AT THE
SCHOOL FOR SCHOOLS. FOR A FOR A
SCHOOL ACTIVITY LOT OF PRIDE AND
TRUST AND RESPECT THEIR WHERE
THEY WOULD NEVER SAY I NEED A
RIDE TO A MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC
BECAUSE OF STIGMA.
PARTICULARLY IN AND CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES NOT YET FIGURED OUT
HOW TO SUPPORT THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEVERAGE THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN OUR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEMS AND OUR SCHOOLS.
IN WAYS THAT YOU'RE SEEING IN
ALAMEDA SO WE SEE THESE POCKETS
OF EXCELLENCE BUT MOVING THOSE
LESSONS FROM A AND AN
EXCEPTIONAL EXPERIENCE IN A
PLACE AT A POINT IN TIME.
INTO A STRATEGIC INITIATIVE FOR
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT.
THE FISCAL INCENTIVES ARE
MISALIGNED INFORMATIONAL
INCENTIVES ARE MISSION LA I
MISALIGNED.
A GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE IT
HIGHLIGHTED IN MY TESTIMONY IN
MY FAMILY I HAVE AND MY COUSIN
HAS A CHILD WHO WAS STRUGGLING
TO GET MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
AND WAS TOLD TO WAIT UNTIL HE
WAS ELIGIBLE FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES.
THE HE WAS THE MY FAMILY WAS
SORT OF PUSHED IN BETWEEN THE
SCHOOLS AND THE COUNTY WITH BOTH
SIDES SAYING THAT'S NOT MY MY
RESPONSIBILITY YET.
LET'S WAIT FOR THIS CHALLENGE TO
GET WORSE TO GET MORE EXPENSIVE
ONE OF THE MESSAGES IN MISTER
BRISCOE'S TESTIMONY TO GET MORE
EXPENSIVE.
UNTIL WE CAN'T AVOID RESPONDING
WE REALLY NEED TO TURN THAT
AROUND.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT BY
SUPPORTING COUNTIES IN TERMS OF
BUILDING LEARNING
COLLABORATIVE'S WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT IN TERMS OF CREATING
INCENTIVE DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES IN SCHOOLS COMING
TOGETHER WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT.
IN TERMS OF LEVERAGING EXISTING
DATA.
WERE TRYING TO WORK WERE WORKING
WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR AROUND
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INNOVATION TO
REALLY SHAPE HOW COMMUNITIES
THINK ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN IN NEW SO THAT INCLUDES
THE SCHOOLS BUT NOT JUST THE
SCHOOLS AND COULD OTHER PARTNERS.
SO AS MUCH AS I THINK TODAY FROM
THE DATA THAT MISTER BRISCOE'S
PRESENTED.
THIS FEELS LIKE A VERY HEAVY
LEFT AT THE SAME TIME I WANT TO
SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE SOME
PHENOMENAL EXAMPLES OUT THERE
AROUND THE STATE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO HELP YOU SEE SOME OF THOSE.
BUT BUT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
WITH THE WAY WE STRUCTURED
FUNDING TORY SYSTEM QUITE OFTEN
ARE LEGAL RULES TO ACTUALLY TAKE
THOSE EXAMPLES AND MOVE THEM TO
SCALE WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT
IT'S IT'S IT'S TOUGH TO DO.
BUT RECOGNIZING THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT WE HAVE THE LEADERSHIP IN
THE COMMUNITIES ARE LEADERSHIP
AND OUR SCHOOLS THE FUNDING THAT
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
PROVIDES AS WELL AS THE THE THE
MANDATE FOR PREVENTION AND AND
INNOVATION WE THINK IT'S QUITE
POSSIBLE.
WE'D LOVE TO HELP YU THINK
ABOUT WAYS TO ACCELERATE THAT WE
HAVE SOME IDEAS ABOUT THAT SOME
OF THOSE ARE LAID OUT IN THE
TESTIMONY --
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY REALLY WHAT I'D LIKE
TO DO IS ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE AND HELP YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
BETTER SOONER FASTER CHEAPER.
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU BOTH AND OFFER
YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
SOME QUESTIONS.
AND I JUST WANNA KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF DOCTOR WEBER --
DOCTOR WOULD.
AND MISTER MCCARTY --
WHO MAY HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR
YOU AS WELL I MIGHT MY QUESTIONS
MAYBE A LITTLE GENERAL --
I CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEED
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AT AT
AT THE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL I'M NOT
SURE THE SCHOOL SITE SHOULD BE
BUILDING THE CAPACITY. TO
DELIVER THOSE SERVICES I THINK
THIS.
FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE SO THAT WE
HAVE THAT THAT THAT EXPERTISE
THAT SPECIFIC.
EXPERTISE --
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER --
YOU KNOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS
CROSTINI PROTOCOLS WHAT WHAT
WHAT DID I DO WHEN I SAW STUDENT
AT I THOUGHT WAS STRUGGLING LIKE
I TOLD THE COUNSELOR.
AND I'M NOT ALWAYS SURE THAT
THAT COUNSELOR HAD AVAILABLE
PROTOCOLS.
WHERE WHERE THEY DO RIGHT THERE
THEY'RE USED ACADEMIC COUNSELING
TYPICALLY OR MAYBE SOME SO YOU
KNOW A SOME?
SOME ISSUES THAT AREN'T SO HEAVY
IS AS A MENTAL ILLNESS SO MAYBE
YOU CAN COMMENT ON THAT BUT I
THINK WE'LL BE DONE HERE A LOT
TODAY IS TO FIND THE PROBLEM.
AND WE'RE GONNA HEAR ABOUT SOME
EXAMPLES BUT I WANT TO HOW WE DO
THIS I WELL THE BILLING SYSTEM
WELL.
YOU KNOW WE WANT ELEAZAR TO BE
ABLE TO BILL RIGHT RIGHT FOR FOR
FOR MEDI CAL.
HEALTH RELATED SERVICES SO
THAT'S KIND OF WHAT I WANT TO
GET I WANT TO GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE SPECIFIC MAYBE YEAH I THINK
THE NEXT TWENTY MAY WISH.
TO RESPOND TO THE SAME QUESTION
BUT I WANNA KNOW HOW IT GETS
DONE ON THE GROUND HOW.
DOES A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
FIND A PROVIDER --
BILL FOR THOSE SERVICES HOW DOES
ALL THIS HAPPEN ON THE GROUND.
NOW I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE SOME
EXAMPLES BUT I WANT I'M MORE
INTO THAT.
I'VE HEARD KIND OF THE PROBLEM
TO FIND AND WE'RE HERE SO EXAMS
WELL ON I'M I'M MORE INTERESTED
IN HOW.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION --
I HEARD ON NPR ON THE WAY UP
HERE THAT THE HEART OF THE SO --
THAT THAT QUESTION SO I HEARD A
QUESTION IN TWO PARTS ONE IS THE
SPECIFICS OF OPERATIONS HOW DOES
IT LOOK LIKE THIS NEXUS OF
HEALTH AND EDUCATION.
SOMEONE ANSWER THAT THE SECOND
IS HOW TO PAY.
FOR ACOSTA FINANCING MECHANISM
SO THE FOR SPECIFICALLY SO THE
FIRST ONE AND WE LEARNED.
WITH A LOT OF COLLABORATIVE --
WITH BLOOD ON THE GROUND SO TO
SPEAK.
OF TRYING TO MERGE THE CULTURE
OF OF HEALTH AND EDUCATION WE
LEARNED THE HARD WAY OVER MANY
YEARS AND WHAT WE LEARNED IS YOU
HAVE TO BE REAL SPECIFIC.
SO IN EVERYONE OF THOSE TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE PROGRAMS
THAT I'M OUT FOR YOU.
THERE IS WHAT'S CALLED A
COORDINATION OF SERVICE TEAM
MEETING THAT HAS TO HAPPEN EVERY
WEEK IT'S GONNA COST TEAM SOME
JURISDICTIONS CALL CARE TEAM.
BUT WHAT IT IS IS A DEFINED
PROTOCOL FOR THE IDENTIFICATION
OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO NEED ACCESS
TO SUPPORT.
THAT'S NOT JUST THE WISDOM AND
SKILL OF A PARTICULAR COUNSELOR.
SO THERE IS A SPECIFIC PROTOCOL
FOR HOW PART OF THE CONTRACT.
BETWEEN THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
COUNTY AND THE PROVIDER.
SO TO YOUR OTHER QUESTION IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE USED A
PURCHASED OR PROCURED MODEL.
MEANING WE WOULD WORK WITH A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
LIKE A SENECA A LINK IN FRENCH
FRENCH AND EAST BAY AGENCY FOR
CHILDREN.
A NONPROFIT ENTITY THAT WAS
CONTRACTED. TO THE MEDICAID
AGENCY WHICH IN THE COUNTY IS
THE PAPER OUT THE PARK.
SO THE SUGGESTION I WOULD MAKE
IS THAT IN MANY COUNTIES THE WAY
TO DO THIS IS TO WORK WITH A TRY
PIE CHART TRIPARTITE AGREEMENT.
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH
AUTHORITY YOUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND YOUR PROVIDER.
NOW THERE ARE MANY JURISDICTIONS
WHERE THE PROVIDERS IS NOT EXIST
IN THAT CASE THE DISTRICT HAS TO
BECOME THE PROVIDER.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW YOU GET
THERE THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
TO DO IT --
AND NEITHER ONE'S OWN YOU KNOW
BOTH WORK --
BUT THE DETAILS OF THE OPERATION
ARE YOU HAVE TO DEFINEYOUR
REFERRAL PROTOCOL YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A COST TEAM.
AND WHAT WE SAID IS YOU HAVE TO
BE ON CAMPUS FULL TIME SO NO
DROP AND THERAPISTS LIKE IT TO
BE THERE ALL THE TIME.
SO MANY QUESTIONS REAL QUICK ON
THAT ONE DAY.
SO -- SIX
FIVE HUNDRED TO UNDER FIFTY
STUDENT ELEMENTARY SCHOOL YOU
WANT A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL IN THEIR FULL TIME --
AT LEAST.
ONE IN FACT WHAT I WOULD SAY
FROM A PANEL PERSPECTIVE FOR SO
IT THE FINANCING DEPENDS ON THE
NUMBER OF THOSE KIDS THAT ARE
MEDICAID ELIGIBLE BECAUSE
THERE'S A FINANCING REALITY
RIGHT YOU GOT TO HAVE.
A PAIR.
SO -- IF IF
IF THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED MEDICAID
KIDS IN THE SCHOOL --
YOU SHOULD GET A SPLIT BETWEEN
TWO TO FOUR FULL TIME
PROFESSIONALS.
TURN MEDICAID HOW HOW I WIND UP
GETTING A FEDERAL ENTITLEMENT.
CALLED E. P. S. T. T. STANCE
EARLY PERIODIC SCREENING AND
DIAGNOSTIC TREATMENT IT'S THE
NAME OF THE FEDERAL BENEFIT. FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FOR CHILDREN IN
MEDICAID.
SO TO FLIP OVER TO THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE ANSWER.
IT'S TO MAKE REAL.
THE FEDERAL ENTITLEMENT TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT ALL
CHILDREN IN MEDICAID ENJOY.
BUT ARE NOT CURRENTLY GETTING.
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF A SERIES
OF WELL INTENTIONED --
BUT ULTIMATELY DISASTROUS POLICY
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
BY THE SENATE STATE SINCE.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR SO.
SO.
THE STATE LAW THAT IS CREATED
THIS HURDLE OR FEDERAL LAW.
OR PADELL FEDERAL LAW CREATES A
BENEFIT OKAY OUR STATE HAS
FAILED IN KEEPING THE PROMISE
[inaudible]
GET.
BY DOING WHAT.
FIRST BY CARVING OUT BEHAVIOR
HEALTH FOR MENTAL HEALTH IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR TO
SOMETHING CALLED THE NINETEEN
FIFTEEN BE WAIVER.
SO IF YOU THINK ABOUT MEDICAID
AS A HEALTH BENEFIT.
YOUR PHYSICAL HEALTH IS
ADMINISTERED BY A MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION.
YOUR MENTAL HEALTH.
IS ADMINISTERED BY YOUR MENTAL
HEALTH PLAN.
THAT'S YOUR COUNTY.
SO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN FIFTEEN THE WAIVER.
AND CREATED THE COUNTY CARVE OUT.
I HAVE TO GO BY HOPE THIS IS
USEFUL BUT THIS IS YOU GOT OF
THE THERAPIST AND YOU SAID YOU
HAD A LOOK BACK TO GO FORWARD.
JUST UNDERSTAND HOW WERE
CONSTRUCTED.
AND CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAID
PROGRAM.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH ME MENTAL HEALTH
ENOUGH ON DRUG ADMINISTERED BY
THE COUNTY PLANS PHYSICAL HEALTH
ARE MISTER BY YOUR MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATIONS.
MET SO THERE IS A PRIVATE PLANS
ARE PUBLIC LANCERS BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE CREATED THIS CAR OUT.
AND THEN WE FOR MANY YEARS
FUNDED ALMOST NOTHING FOR
CHILDREN.
IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE LEGAL
ADVOCACY OF CAN DAHLE SHEA AND
AND HELP AND PATRICK GARDNER
YOUNG MINDS ADVOCACY IN OTHERS.
THERE WAS A LAWSUIT IN THE LATE
NINETIES THAT SAID THE STATE IS
NOT MEETING ITS OBLIGATION.
THUS WAS BORN THE EPS TO T.
BENEFIT.
AND FOR THE FIRST TIME COUNTIES
GOT MONEY TO SERVE KIDS
BEGINNING IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS.
NOT COINCIDENTALLY TIMED WITH
THE EXPANSION THAT I SHOWED YOU
UP ON THE ON THE POWER POINT. TO
BEGIN THE LATE NINETIES EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS COUNTY AND
MEDICAID MENTAL HEALTH THROUGH
EPS DUTY.
SOME I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT
HISTORY UNKNOWNS DETAILED BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
BIFURCATION OF THE MIND AND BODY
IN CALIFORNIA'S MEDICAID PROGRAM.
COUNTY IS THE MAIL HEALTH PLAN.
MEDICARE MANAGED CARE THE FIFTH
OF THIS IS A HEALTH PLAN.
AND HOW IT'S BEEN FINANCED --
AND COUNTIES HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
THE RESOURCES AND THEY'VE BEEN
CREATED AND THEY'VE BEEN GIVEN
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN THAT I
BELIEVES ON REASONABLE.
SO THE WAY FORWARD TO GIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACCESS TO THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO DO THE
WORK WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
IS TO REFORM.
THE MEDICAID PROGRAM IN MENTAL
HEALTH.
AND GIVE KIDS THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO UNDER
FEDERAL LAW [inaudible]
SO -- CAN I
CAN A LOCAL SCHOOL I'M SORRY THE
KIND OF LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
BELT BILL CAN ALLEY A BILL.
WHO WHO THEY BILL YEAH SO
THERE'S --
SOME TO SOME GREAT WORK FROM C.
T. A AND THE NURSES THERE'S BEEN
A NEW BILLING MECHANISM SO I'M.
AND I'M AGAIN I HOPE THIS IS
USEFUL BUT IF YOU WANT TO GET A
MEDICAID DOLLAR.
THERE'S BASICALLY THREE WAYS TO
GET YOUR BILL YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN.
YOUR BILL YOUR PHYSICAL HEALTH
PLAN OR YOUR BILL THE STATE
DIRECT.
AND THE LA A IS HAVE TWO WAYS TO
GET MONEY FROM THE STATE DIRECT.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH YES FOR FROM
HEALTH CARE PERIOD BECAME THE
FIRST IS L. E. A ADMINISTRATIVE
ACTIVITIES WHICH MEANS FOR ALL
THE WORK IT DOES TO HELP KIDS
GET ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM TO
CONNECT THEM TO CARE.
BUT IT'S A DIFFICULT THING TO
BILL IT'S HARD IT'S
ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME.
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE IN OAKLAND
OAKLAND GOT A ALMOST EIGHT
HUNDRED GRAND VALLEY A MEDICAID
ADMINISTRATIVE ACTIVITIES AND WE
SPENT OVER FORTY MILLION.
OF THE PSG MOUTH SO NOW WE MáS
SMALL.
THERE IS NEWLY AGAIN THROUGH THE
ADVOCACY OF ITS CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION AND OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES ASSOCIATION
THE SCHOOL NURSES.
THERE HAS RECENTLY BEEN MOVEMENT
THAT WILL ALLOW ELEAZAR TO BILL
MEDICAID DIRECTOR SOMETHING
CALLED THE L. EAT A BILLING
OPTION PROGRAM HOW WE A. B. O.
P..
AND THAT EXISTS.
THAT THAT'S A NEW.
I WOULD ARGUE AGAIN THOUGH THAT
IT'S A DIFFICULT AND BURDENSOME
PATHWAY TO BRING RESOURCES TO
THE TWO AT THE SCALE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
REMEMBER THOSE THREE SOURCES I
TOLD YOU GET MEDICAID CAN GET IT
THROUGH THE ALLEY A OPTION.
YOU CAN GET YOUR MENTAL HEALTH
PLAN WE GET IT THROUGH YOUR
MENTAL HEALTH PLAN DOES THE
BASICALLY THE THREE WAYS YOU GET
ACCESS TO MEDICAID.
I THINK THIS ELLIE A STUFF IS
TOO SMALL TO MATTER AT THE SCALE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
AND THAT IS WE HAVE THE BEST
CELL WHY THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE
OR WHAT YEAH BECAUSE THINK OF
MEDICARE LIKE A POT OF GOLD IN
DC YOU GET A DOLLAR IF YOU PUT
UP A DOLLAR.
SO.
WHEN I LIAISE BILL MEDICAID THEY
STILL HAVE TO PUT UP THE DOLLAR
TO GET THE DOLLAR?
SO THAT'S ASKING DISTRICTS TO
INVEST YOUR MONEY AND EVEN
WHAT'S ONLY FIFTY CENTS ON THE
DOLLAR IT'S FIFTY CENTS MORE
THAN I GOT.
I ALSO THINK WE NEED TO STOP
ASKING SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE
THERAPISTS AND DOCTORS LET THEM
EDUCATE.
BUT THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO ITS
OP IT'S MEET ITS OBLIGATION AND
BY THE WAY THEY HAVE A LOT MORE
MONEY.
SO THAT'S WHY YOUR HEARING IN MY
OPINIONATED STATEMENT --
THAT I BELIEVE THAT THE PATHWAY
FOR TO BRING RESOURCES TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT SCALE IS NOT TO
FORCE THEM INTO THE ALLEY A
BILLING PLAY --
DISTRICTS WILL DO IT AND SOME
WILL BE SOMEWHAT SUCCESSFUL AT
IT BUT I THINK IT'S FOOL'S GOLD.
THE REAL WAY TO BRING THESE TYPE
OF SERVICES TO SCALE ON SCHOOL
CAMPUSES IS TO FILL THE EPS TT
MANDATE.
THAT WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THAT OUR STATE HAS
FAILED TO DELIVER.
THANK YOU AND WE MAYBE.
DEBBIE THE CONSULTANT WHO WHO
HANDLES THIS MATTER MAYBE I'M
SURE USE YOU'VE HAD INTERACTION
OBVIOUSLY BEFORE BUT I I THINK
WHAT WE NEED IS IS THE DETAIL
WHICH YOU JUST DELIVERED.
A QUITE FRANKLY BECAUSE WE KEEP
SAYING WHERE IS IT WHERE IS IT
WHERE IS IT WE KEEP WAITING AND
CLEARLY THERE'S THERE'S
SOMETHING FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
THAT IS NOT CONNECTING YOUR AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
BUT EVEN OVERALL HEALTH SERVICES
AT THE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL LISTEN
I COME FROM HIGH SCHOOL FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS I'M SURE YOU
CAN EMPLOY A FULL TIME DOCTOR
PLUS. FOR JUST THAT HIGH SCHOOL
SO THE QUESTION IS HOW DO YOU
BUILD IT THERE WHAT IS IT THAT
HOW DO YOU BILL HOW DO YOU GET.
THIS DONE BECAUSE EVER SINCE
THIS BUT I DON'T FEEL LIKE IT'S
HAPPENING SO WE MOVED SOMEHOW WE
NEED TO CONNECT THESE TO THESE
TO VENTURE SOME SORRY SIR AT ALL
TO CHAIR I WOULD AND I WOULDN'T
WILL NOT DISAGREE WITH MR RISCO
I WOULD ANSWER THE QUESTION A
BIT.
DIFFERENTLY I I THINK THAT --
IN SOME SCENARIOS THAT SOLUTION
IS A VIABLE SOLUTION BECAUSE OF
THE NUMBERS BECAUSE OF THE
CAPACITY BECAUSE OF THE WORK
FORCE RESOURCES AS HE SAID.
ALAMEDA HAD SOME SOME SOME
EXTERNAL IN OF RESOURCES
RESOURCES OTHER THEY COULD DRAW
THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK IN ALL
TERRACE.
AND AND SO THE QUESTION OF HOW
DO WE DO THAT HOW TO SUPPORT
THAT WHAT WE'RE FINDING A LOT OF
SMALLER RURAL COMMUNITIES AS
THEY'RE FIGURING IT OUT THERE
THIRD BUILDING THESE
PARTNERSHIPS THEY'RE CAUGHT IN
ITS ITS THE PICKING UP THE PHONE
AND ARE CALLING THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH TRACK.
AND SAYING HEY HOW DO WE MAKE
THIS WORK AND IN ALL TERRACE
THIS THAT MENTAL HEALTH STAFF
ACTUALLY.
SEE SEE CONSUMERS AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL THEY WERE THEY WALK ON
THE CAMPUS BECAUSE IT'S A SMALL
TOWN BECAUSE THEY CAN BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SO FEW PEOPLE THIS
RELATIONSHIP FOR THEIR WHERE
WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR IS.
HOW CAN THE STATE FACILITATE
MANY PASSED TO GET THERE CLEARLY
THERE ARE SOME STRUCTURAL ISSUES
THAT HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED IN
TERMS OF FINANCING SOME
COMMUNITIES WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT AND PUT THOSE
RESOURCES?
IN PLACE TO EXACTLY AS ALAMEDA
HAS DONE.
BUT IN OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT
MIGHT NOT WORK FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS THE PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN IN IN SANTA
CLARA FOR EXAMPLE THEY'RE MAKING
A FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO CREATE.
A WHAT'S WHAT'S CALL THAT IT'S
AN INTEGRATED USE MENTAL HEALTH
AND PHYSICAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
TARGETING.
YOUTH FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE SO
TRUMP RECALL TRANSITION
EIGHTIETH AND THEY'RE DESIGNING
THIS USING HIM TO SAY INNOVATION
FUNDS TO SERVE EVERY USED IN THE
COUNTY.
THAT CAN COME IN REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT IT HOW DOES NOT
HAVE MEDI CAL HAS KAISER
INSURANCE.
AND SO WHAT WHAT WE'RE BEGINNING
TO LOOK AT IS HOW CAN THE STATE
FACILITATE MULTIPLE PATHS SO
THAT WE CAN DESIGN STRATEGIES
THAT ARE APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
FOR THE SCENARIO.
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WERE ALSO
TRYING TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTUREIN TERMS OF USING
ADMINISTRATIVE DATA TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WORK FOR HOME IN
WHAT COMMUNITIES IN WHICH WAY IS.
IT MAY BE THAT IN SOME PLACES
THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CLINIC
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO. FOR
OTHERS PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO
ARE LEAVING SCHOOL BUT MIGHT
NEED CONTINUOUS CARE THEY MIGHT
NOT WANT TO GO BACK TO THEIR
HIGH SCHOOL AT NINETEEN OR
TWENTY OR TWENTY ONE TO CONTINUE
THAT SERVICE.
SO I THINK WHILE NOT DISAGREEING
SUGGESTING THAT. ONE SIZE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY FIT ALL.
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
IS HOW DO WE ARRAY FISCAL
INCENTIVES.
PROGRAMMATIC SUPPORT TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND OTHER STRAIGHT LEADERSHIP
STRATEGIES AROUND DATA AROUND
REGULATORY RULES SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THE
EXPERIMENTATION AND INVESTMENTS
IN THE STRATEGIES THAT SCHOOLS
AND COUNTIES COULD WORK OUT
TOGETHER.
IN WAYS TO DO EXACTLY WHAT
MISTER BRISCOE'S CALLING FOR
THAT THEN LEAD TO CHANGES IN HOW
THESE COMMUNITIES CAN ACCESS
DOLLARS.
SO THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
RESPONSIVE TO THE STRATEGIES NOT
THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
THANK YOU ENOUGH TO THINK THANK
YOU FOR THE DETAILS.
APOLOGIZE TO COMMITTEE FOR
TAKING OF THAT AMOUNT OF TIME
BUT I FELT IT WAS NECESSARY TO
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS ARE THERE
OTHERS THAT WAS TO COME A DOCTOR
WOULD.
YEAH.
FIRST ONE NOT AN EDUCATOR --
I'M A I'M A HEALTH CARE PROVIDER.
AND BUT A COUPLE THINGS STRUCK
ME AS YOUR TO IT'S SYSTEM SO --
WHICH IS SOMETHING WE ENCOUNTER
HAS PROVIDERS SO WITH YOUR
DENTIST OR PHYSICIAN IT'S IT'S
IT'S CUMBERSOME IT'S DIFFICULT --
IS IT I GUESS I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IS A DIFFICULT.
ARE YOU ARE THERE A LOT OF
DENIALS --
BECAUSE I WILL TELL YOU MAY.
WITH --
FORMER CONGRESSMAN PATRICK
KENNEDY YESTERDAY TALKED ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES OF GETTING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WITH YOUR
TRADITIONAL HEALTH CARE PLAN
WORK.
OFTENTIMES THE DENIAL RATE IS
MUCH HIGHER THAN IT IS IN OTHER
KINDS OF CARE AND SO I'M CURIOUS
IS THAT IS THAT PART OF THE
ISSUE OR IS IT A TECHNICAL ISSUE
OR BECAUSE A LOT OF YEARS.
YEAH SO I'M FOR AGAIN I BUT BY
WELCOME THIS QUESTION AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR INTEREST IN THE
DETAIL -- IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN EVEN
EXAMPLE FROM THE PHYSICAL HOW
SPACE CAMP IN NINETEEN NINETY
SIX IF YOU HAD MEDICAID IN
CALIFORNIA.
YOU HAD A CAR THAT SAID MEDICAID
AND HAD FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE.
I WAS LIKE HAVING A TICKET TO
NOWHERE BECAUSE NO ONE WOULD
TAKE THE RATES RIGHT.
SO CAN BASH A AND OTHERS AT THE
STATE.
MEET IS BRAVE DECISION THAT SAID
LOOK IF PEOPLE CAN GET ACCESS TO
CARE WE GOT A CHANGE HOW WE PAY.
SO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WENT
THROUGH THIS TRANSFORMATION
CALLED MEDI CAL CONSOLIDATION
WHICH IS A FANCY TERM FOR THE
MOVEMENT TO MANAGE CARE.
SO WE WENT FROM 90% OF PEOPLE IF
YOU FOR SERVICE TODAY 90% OF
PEOPLE MANAGED CARE.
WE CAN BRING BEHAVIOR HEALTH
WITH US.
IN FACT WE DID EVEN WORSE THAN
THAT.
IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
YOU HAVE TO BILL PER MINUTE.
PER UNIT.
PER PATIENT PER DIAGNOSIS.
SO THINK FOR SECOND IF YOU'RE
NOT MY WIFE IS A PEDIATRICIAN
SHE RUNS A NUCLEAR SF GENERAL.
HOW YOU GONNA DIAGNOSIS TWO YEAR
OLD?
WHEN THEIR MOMS ANXIETY
DEPRESSION IS WAS REALLY CAUSING
THE BEHAVIOR CHALLENGE?
SO WE HAVE CREATED A A
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM THAT'S
DRIVEN BY PATHOLOGY WITH THE
UNIQUE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN.
BEHAVIOR HEALTH IT'S HARDER TO
BUILD THAN ANYTHING A PHYSICAL
HEALTH BAYLOR HAS TO BILL.
YOU KNOW I'VE RUN AFTER IT SEES.
I'VE FILLED HOSPITAL COST
REPORTS I EACH OF BILLING
MEDICAID MENTAL HEALTH.
IN FACT 55% OF THE TIME THAT
CLINICIANS SPEND 55%.
IS SPENT BILLING.
SO ALL THE SHOULD THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE SHORTAGES
OF CHILD PSYCHIATRIST.
NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF THEM BUT WE'RE HAVING TO
SPEND MORE THAN HALF THE TIMES
ON A PAPERWORK.
IT'S INSANE.
SO IT AGAIN I WOULD INVITE YOU
THAT IF WE WERE GONNA DO ONE
THING.
WE'D REFORM HOW MEDICAID
BEHAVIOR.
IS STRUCTURED AND REIMBURSED.
AND I KNOW THAT SEEMS LIKE MAYBE
FAR AWAY FROM THE NEEDS OF A
TEACHER BUT IT'S NOT.
IT'S WHAT'S GONNA STOP US FROM
BRINGING THE SERVICES TO KIDS ON
CAMPUSES EVEN THOUGH THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO THEM AND THEY SHOULD
BE GETTING TO YOU SHOULD BE
GETTING THE THERE'S A QUESTION.
YEAH SADLY S..
AND LIKE I'D LIKE TO ADD ON TO
THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE IS
DOESN'T GET EASIER BETTER ON THE
PRIVATE SECTOR SIDE.
NOW.
SO THAT IF.
IF YOU HAVE A CHILD TODAY IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
WHO IS EXHIBITING EARLY SIGNS OF
PSYCHOSIS?
UC DAVIS RUNS.
SOME OF THE BEST PROGRAMS IN THE
COUNTY AND THEY HAVE ANOTHER
PSYCHOSIS CLINIC FOR PEOPLE WITH
PRIVATE SECTOR INSURANCE.
AND EARLY PSYCHOSIS CLINIC FOR
PEOPLE WITH MEDICARE NOW YOU
WANT YOUR CHILD IN MEDI CAL.
THE QUALITY OF THE CARE WHAT'S
COVERED.
RIGHT PART OF THE REASON WHY
WE'RE PUTTING ALL THIS PRESSURE.
ON THIS PUBLIC SYSTEM IN SOME
WAYS IS BECAUSE WE'VE ALSO.
WELL WE'VE SEEN TREMENDOUS
ADVANCES IN THE QUALITY OF CARE
THAT YOU CAN GET THROUGH THE
PRIVATE MARKET WE'RE NOT SEEING
THOSE ADVANCES.
ON THE BAY FOR A WHOLE SIDE.
RIGHT WE WE HAVE SO IT'S NOT
JUST ON THE MEDI CAL SITE IS
HARD TO FIND THE PROVIDER
BECAUSE THE BILLING IT'S HARD.
IT'S INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE WITH PRIVATE SECTOR
INSURANCE AS WELL.
AND SO I SO I I WANT TO CONNECT
THESE TWO BECAUSE MANY OF THE
CHILDREN WERE TALKING ABOUT HALF
PRIVATE INSURANCE.
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM WHETHER IT'S A COUNTY OR
A CONTRACTOR WHOSE FOR SERVING
THOSE CHILDREN ACCESSING THE
FUNDS.
THAT THE FAMILIES PAID INTO IN
TERMS OF PREMIUMS TO MAKE SURE
THEIR CHILDREN ARE GETTING CARE
SO THERE'S DISCONNECTS BETWEEN
WHAT PEOPLE NEED CHILDREN NEED.
AND THE PUBLIC DOLLAR AND
THERE'S A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
WHAT PEOPLE NEED AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR DOLLARS WHILE.
WHAT I HEARD YESTERDAY FROM A
FORMER CONGRESSMAN WAS THAT --
THE DENIAL RATE FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES IS HIGHER THAN
ANY OTHER SERVICE PROVIDED --
IN MEDICINE.
THAT THAT WAS.
WHAT HE PERCEIVED AS A NATION
WIDE SO I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA --
BUT IF IT'S ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
THAT IT'S IT'S PRETTY DISTURBING.
AND IF IF I COULD MAKE ONE MORE
COMMENT AT IF 60% OF THE KIDS
ARE MEDICAID AND FEDERAL
ENTITLED THIS BENEFIT.
IN A ONE SUGGESTION WOULD BE TO
FOLLOW MY RECOMMENDATION WHICH
IS TO ACTIVATE THE H. YES AND
REQUIRE THE STATE GIVE YOU A
PLAN. TO MEET THE THE THE
DETAILS THE MANDATE.
ON THE PRIVATE SIDE YOU DO HAVE
A LEVER.
THE FEDERAL PARITY ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT ESSENTIAL BENEFIT
PACKAGE OF THE AFFORDABLE CARE
ACT REQUIRE THAT PRIVATE
INSURERS.
OFFER THE SAME ACCESS TO
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AS THEY USED AS
WEALTH.
WE AS A STATE ARE LATE TO
ENFORCEMENT.
SO TO ADOPT JUST TO SAY WE DON'T
HAVE TO JUST LEAVE THAT IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT MEDICAID THOUGH
MEDICAID'S GO IMPORTANT.
AND IT'S 60% OF GETS THE THERE
IS A STRATEGY FOR THE
COMMERCIALLY INSURED FOLKS.
TO THAT I THINK THE ELECTED TO
PURSUE.
AND THEN ONE FINAL QUESTION TO
THIS YEAR --
DOCTOR EWING YOU TALKED ABOUT
THE ALTIRIS AND IT SOUNDS LIKE A
UNIQUE APPROACH IT SOUNDS IT CAN
YOU WALK ME THROUGH THAT A
LITTLE BIT WAS T IS IT WAS IT
MENTAL HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
THROUGH THE COUNTY OR THEIR
THROUGH THE CITY.
THEY'RE NOT AFFILIATED WITH THE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO BILL TO NINE I'M INTO A
LOT OF SMALL TOWNS IN MY
DISTRICT YEAH THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
I WENT UP THERE INSTANCE OF TIME
WITH THEIR COUNTY STAFF AND THAT
THEY JUST HAVE RELATIONSHIPS
WITH INDIVIDUAL TEACHERS IN THE
SCHOOLS AND SO YEAH THESE ARE
COUNTY STAFF.
THEY THEY SHOULD STRUGGLE FOR TO
FIND PRIVATE PROVIDERS IN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND SO I MEAN IT IT
REALLY IS YOU KNOW A SMALL MY
FAMILY'S FROM WE'D.
RIDE IS A SMALL TOWN AND AND SO
IT REALLY IS THIS REALLY.
WHAT WE SEE IS QUITE OFTEN
RELATIONSHIP BASED STRATEGIES
WHETHER IT'S IN FRESNO OR
MONTEREY OR OUT TERRACE?
IN SOME OF THE STRATEGIES ARE
VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH THE IDEA
OF PUTTING A HEALTH CLINIC IN A
SCHOOL.
BUT IN SOME OF OUR SMALLER
COMMUNITIES THAT'S NOT
FINANCIALLY VIABLE OR THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WORK FORCE.
SO MIGHT MY COMMENT ABOUT ALL
TERRACE IS THEY FOUND A PATH BUT
QUITE OFTEN THAT GETS
EXCEPTIONALLY DIFFICULT THERE'S
LOTS OF WORK AROUNDS.
BECAUSE THEY'RE BUMPING UP
AGAINST THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS OF THE RULES OF THE
INFORMATION SHARING OR HOW THIS
INFORMATION FLOWS AND AND AND
AND MY MY OVERARCHING COMMENT IS
THE STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
MULTIPLE STRATEGIES. TO MAKE IT
EASIER FOR COUNTIES AND SCHOOLS
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AS PARTNERS.
WE HAVE MODELS OUT THERE IN OUT
TERRACE IN ALAMEDA BUT WHAT WE
HAVEN'T DONE IS LEARN FROM THEM
PUT THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN
PLACE PUT THE SUPPORT IN PLACE
TO TAKE THOSE MODEL PROGRAMS.
AND ACTUALLY TAKE THEM TO SCALE
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE IS ACTUALLY BEEN TRYING TO
DO.
IN WAYS THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THESE COUNTIES TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
THANK YOU. FOR THE COMMENTS.
MISTER RATHER.
I JUST A QUICK QUESTION --
FOR MISTER --
BRISCOE AND THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS THIS IS WILD THAT
DOCTOR EWING YOU MENTIONED I
THINK THAT YOU'D LIKE TO SEE TO
THE FOUR MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS FOR SCHOOL FIVE
HUNDRED IS THE IS TO HAVE SUCH
KIND OF WANNA I'M WONDERING
WHERE THAT NUMBER.
COMES FROM I'M SURE A LOT OF IT
DEPENDS ON WHAT KIND OF SCHOOL
OR DEAL WITH WESTERN POPULATIONS
DIFFERENT AGES WHAT KIND OF
CULTURE THE SCHOOLS BUILT AROUND
ACCESS IN MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
KIND OF LIKE.
USING ONE SIZE DOESN'T THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY FIT ALSO IS
THERE RESEARCH SORT OF
ESTABLISHING WHAT WHAT IS THE
IDEAL RATIO --
FOR FOR THOSE SORT OF SUPPORT
FOLKS.
I KNOW --
AND THEY SHOULD BE IN THE FISCAL
HEALTH WORLD RECALL IMPAIRMENT.
MEANING THE NUMBER OF PATIENTS
ASSIGNED TO A PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER.
pHOW MANY PEOPLE SHOULD BE PANEL
PER PROVIDER.
THERE'S GREAT AND GOOD DETAIL ON
THE PHYSICAL HEALTH PRIMARY CARE
SIDE BETWEEN TWELVE HUNDRED AND
TWO THOUSAND PATIENTS PER
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER.
WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME ANNOUNCES
THE NUMBER I GAVE YOU IS A
FINANCIAL --
POLL MEANING FOR WHAT SIZE
POPULATION COULD YOU SUSTAIN
THROUGH ANY JUST EIGHTY CONTRACT.
HOW MANY PEOPLE COULD YOU STAND
AT ITS MY ESTIMATE BASED ON MY
OWN ROUGH EXPERIENCE IN ONE
COUNTY SO I I WOULD --
CAUTION YOU TO TAKE THAT I SAW
DOCTOR --
ASSEMBLY PERSON OR CENTER CHOOSE
BILL THE MORE MORE PEOPLE
POSITIVE ADULTS IN THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN THE BETTER --
BUT I THINK THAT THAT IS A ALSO
A VERY HIGH BAR FROM A COST
PERSPECTIVE.
CANCERS I DON'T I DO NOT KNOW
WHAT THE RIGHT NUMBERS AND I
WOULD I WOULD BE WARY THAT YOU
TOOK WHAT I SAID TODAY AS ANY
KIND OF RESEARCH BASED.
FACT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER OF BRISCOE AND
DOCTOR TELL ME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
FOR I WILL NOW CALL OF OUR NEXT
PANEL.
OUR SECOND PANEL DEALS WITH HOW
SCHOOLS ARE CURRENTLY PROMOTING
MENTAL WELLNESS AMONG ALL
STUDENTS AND WE'LL HAVE A MISTER
MIKE LOMBARDO FROM THE PLASTER
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AND LISA EISENBERG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BASED.
BASED HEALTH ALLIANCE JOIN US
TODAY AND YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY [inaudible]
YEAH.
OKAY THAT WAS A LOT OF
INFORMATION. FOR A LOT MORE --
CABS --
THINKING WITH SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME MY NAME IS MIKE TOMORROW MY
PLASTER COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
THEY'RE AT PLUS OUR COUNTY I AM
RESPONSIBLE FOR PREVENTION
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES I PLAYED
DOOR ROTH ALSO WITH THE STATE.
AND HELPING TO SUPPORT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PROGRAM THAT
I'LL TALK ABOUT LATER.
THIS AFTERNOON CALL POSITIVE
BEHAVIOR INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORTS.
WELL THE LAST TWO SPEAKERS WERE
TALK AND I STARTED TO THINK
ABOUT THE COMPLEXITY OF
CALIFORNIA SO BEFORE I LAUNCH
INTO PLASTER COUNTY.
I'M REMINDED THAT WE HAVE FIFTY
EIGHT UNIQUE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH A LOT OF
GEOGRAPHIC ECONOMIC AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY.
WE HAVE OVER ELEVEN HUNDRED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. TEN THOUSAND
SCHOOLS AT ABOUT. SIX POINT
THREE MILLION CHILDREN THAT WERE
EDUCATED NINETY SEVEN THOUSAND
OR NINETY THREE THOUSAND OR SO
PLASTER COUNTY.
I DO SOME WORK IN ALPINE COUNTY
ONE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
IN THE DISTRACTOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE TO GO TO A
SEPARATE COUNTY TO ATTEND HIGH
SCHOOL.
SO WHAT MISTER YOU AND SAID I
THINK IS VERY ACCURATE THERE'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL --
MODEL OR OR STRATEGY --
OF STUDENT HER MENTAL HEALTH
CLINICIAN --
CLINICIAN I THINK --
IN PLASTER CAN I'LL TALK ABOUT
THAT NOW.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT INTEGRATION
WE NEED TO LOOK AT PARTNER
AGENCIES WE NEED TO LOOK AT
COLLABORATION.
AND WHO DO WE GET TO THE TABLE
AND EACH OF THE COUNTIES TO HELP
MAKE A SYSTEM AND DESIGN A
SYSTEM THAT'S RESPONSIVE TO OUR
CHILDREN AND FAMILY NEEDS.
AND PLASTER COUNTY WE HAVE A
MODEL CALLED THE CHILDREN SYSTEM
OF CARE.
WHICH I WORKED IN FOR ABOUT
TWENTY OF THE THIRTY ONE YEAR
HISTORY.
THAT PLUS OR SYSTEM OF CARE HAS
BEEN IN PLACE I'VE BEEN ARE
PROVISIONAL SIR.
HI WAS ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF OUR
CHILD WELFARE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES --
I'VE RUN THE JUVENILE
INSTITUTION IN PLASTER COUNTY.
AND YOU MIGHT SAY I CAN'T KEEP A
JOB -- BUT
LAST YEAR OR A LOT ABOUT EIGHT
YEARS AGO I MOVED EDUCATION AND
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN
A UNIQUE WAY AM CLASS OR TO
INTEGRATE OUR SERVICES.
SO CLASS OR COUNTY OUR SYSTEM OF
CARE AS I SAID AS ABOUT A THIRTY
ONE YEAR HISTORY OF INTEGRATION
SERVICES THIS IS DRIVEN BY A
LEADERSHIP TEAM THAT'S PRESIDED.
ARE --
THAT'S CHAIRED BY A PRESIDING
JUDGE.
THAT SEEMS BEEN MADE IN AT SEVEN
THIRTY IN THE MORNING EVERY
WEDNESDAY EVERY OTHER WEDNESDAY
NOW FOR THE LAST --
WE HAD IT THIS MORNING FOR THOSE
LAST THIRTY YEARS.
WHAT'S THE GOAL OF COORDINATING
WITH THE SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICER DIRECTOR OF HUMAN
SERVICES THE DIRECTOR FAMILY
ADVOCACY SO WE HAVE A FAMILY
MEMBER WITH LIVED EXPERIENCE ON
THAT TEAM.
AND OUR DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S
SYSTEM OF CARE AND THEN STAFFED
BY SUPPORT CAN HELP THIS HAPPEN.
SO WAVERLY OF REALLY FIRMLY THAT
NOBODY CAN DO IT BY THEMSELVES
SCHOOLS CAN'T I'VE WORKED ON ALL
OF THESE AGENCIES.
AND SCHOOLS CAN'T DO IT ALONE
THAT IT TAKES THAT INTEGRATED
MODEL.
IT TAKES COLLABORATION --
IT'S A HEAVY LIFT AND IT'S HARD
WORK BUT I I BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
OUR VALUES OUR PLACE IN THE
FAMILY AT THE CENTER OF OUR
SERVICES.
WE VALUE YOUTH INVOLVEMENT YOU
FOR USE THEIR CONTRACTS WE
EMPLOYEE YOUTH WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE WE IMPLORE.
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH LEFT
EXPERIENCE WHO ARE INTEGRATED ON
TO TEAMS.
SERVICES TEAMS WITH CHILD
WELFARE PROBATION MENTAL HEALTH --
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO HELP SUPPORT
SOME OF THE FAMILIES WITH THE
HIGHEST NEEDS IN OUR COUNTY.
CO LOCATED SHARE DATA SYSTEMS AS
I SAID I'M WITH --
EDUCATION I HAVE FOSTER YOUR
STAFF THAT ACCESS OR CHILD
WELFARE INFORMATION SYSTEM.
SO THEY DON'T NEED TO WAIT FIVE
DAYS TEN DAYS TO HAVE A SOCIAL
WORKER RESPOND THEY CAN GO AND
SAY THAT THIS CHILD WAS DETAINED.
WHERE THEY LIVE AND HOW DO WE
GET SUPPORT FOR THAT STUDENT IN
SCHOOL TODAY OR HOW DO WE
TRANSPORT THAT STUDENT TO SCHOOL
TODAY?
SO COMMITMENT TO CHILDREN YOUTH
AND FAMILIES LIVING IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE MOST INCLUSIVE
MANNER.
KEEPING THEM SAFE HEALTH A HOME
AND SCHOOL SO WE HAVE THIS
HISTORY OF WORKING AT THAT LEVEL.
WE HAVE INTEGRATED TEAMS
THROUGHOUT OUR AGENCY --
ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO TROUT
FROM TRANSIT PREVENTION THROUGH
THE MANAGEMENT RANKS UP TO AS I
MENTIONED THE EXECUTIVE
LEADERSHIP TEAM.
HE HEARD FROM MR REX PRESS.
I'M SORRY.
BRISTOL AND SERBIA AND ABOUT THE
COMPLEXITY THAT THE NEED AND I
THINK YOU'VE HAD OTHER HERE AND
SIGNED --
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
AND THE RATE OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND SCHOOLS.
PLASTER COUNTY --
IN AN EFFORT TO DEEPEN OUR
COLLABORATION --
THROUGH FUND AND THROUGH THE
MENTAL HEALTH OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION NOW.
AS CREATING THAT SYSTEM OF CARE
THAT INTEGRATED MODEL AT SCHOOL
SITES.
SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO TEACH
SCHOOLS AND DISTRACTS HOW DO YOU
CREATE A SYSTEM OF CARE MODEL AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT KOSTER
THE CARE MODEL.
AT A SCHOOL SITE WHAT STRUCTURES
JUNAID IN PLACE WHAT
COMMUNICATION AGREEMENTS WHAT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS.
AND WHO NEEDS TO BEON THOSE
TEAMS AT EACH OF THOSE SCHOOL
SITES AND ITS UNIQUE IT WOULD BE
A DIFFERENT OUT TERRORISTS OR
ALPINE AS IT IS AND PLASTERED IT
MAY BE DIFFERENT AND BE TRAINED --
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH IN HIGH SCHOOLS WE
WANT THOSE TEAMS --
INTEGRATED TEAM SYSTEM AFTER
TEAM THE ECOLOGY OF THAT SCHOOL
TEN OF OFF PARENTS.
AS PART OF THE TEAM TO HELP MAKE
DECISIONS FOCUSED ON YEARS AND
DATA.
SYSTEMS FOR SUPPORT AND STUDENTS
AND WHAT PRACTICES CAN WE PUT IN
PLACE TO HELP THOSE STUDENTS.
ACHIEVE THE OUTCOMES WE WANT TO
SAY [inaudible]
WE THE LADY IF THAT.
MORE ISN'T ALWAYS BETTER.
SO I THINK IT TAKES A COMMUNITY
AND I'VE KIND OF MADE THAT POINT
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE AN
INTEGRATED.
GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS SUPPORTING
KIDS AND FAMILIES PREVENT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN IN A WAY THAT IS
ORGANIZED.
SO -- A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
SUPPORTED FUNDING FOR MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT WORKING WITH
SCHOOLS AND NEEDS TO BE AN
ORGANIZED FASHION WHAT DO WE DO
FOR ALL STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY
BEHAVIORALLY AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONALLY.
HOW DO WE CREATE SYSTEMS OR
WEAKENED SCAFFOLD PRACTICES TO
THOSE SYSTEMS AND RESPOND TO
STUDENT NAMES WHAT DO WE DO FOR
ALL STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY WHAT?
ARE THE EARLY LITERACY PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE THAT EVERY STUDENT
HOW DO WE USE DATA TO RESPOND
WHEN STUDENTS.
HAVE A HIGHER NEED --
AT CHAIR TO LEVEL SUPPORTER
TERRITORY LEVEL OF SUPPORT MORE
INTENSIVE LEVELS OF SUPPORT.
I BELIEVE THAT WE ALSO NEED TO
GO AND I HAVE A A CHART ON THE
LAST PAGE THAT SAYS THE THE
GROWTH A POSITIVE BEHAVIOR AND
INTERVENTIONS AND SUPPORTS AND
CALIFORNIA I BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED.
TO REALLY FOCUS ON HELPING TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL SITES BE MORE
SAFE ADEQUATE OF ALL.
CHAIR ENGAGED ENVIRONMENTS AND
PHOEBE I. S. HELPS DO THAT AND
ACCOMPLISH THAT CALL.
YES IT'S NOW IMPLEMENTED IN OVER
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE.
WE'VE SEEN A RAPID GROWTH OF A
P. B. I. S. IN CALIFORNIA --
PART OF THE REASON IS THAT
SCHOOLS ARE FIND IN THAT WHEN
YOU IMPLEMENTED T. V. I. US WEST
OF AFFECT EFFECTIVELY.
HE HE SEE REDUCTIONS IN JUST A
PLAN.
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR.
YOU SEE INCREASES IN ACADEMIC
AND ENGAGE MEN AND THE CHIEF
MATT.
IMPROVE PERCEPTIONS OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY AT SCHOOL.
WE SEE EVEN A DECREASE IN TWO
JOB SATISFACTION TEACHERS FELLOW
MORE IN CASE I PERSONALLY GONE
TO SCHOOL SITES AND HAD TEACHER
SERVICE REJECT THIS YEARS AGO.
YEAH YES HOUSE TO SUPPORT
DISTRACTS TRADE AND THAT
FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT.
WE HAVE CORE INSTRUCTION --
FOR STUDENTS AROUND LITERACY AND
MATH WE ALSO WANT TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS AROUND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
LEARNING AND AND TEACH AND
SOCIAL EXPECTATIONS SO WE CAN
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT THAT'S
MEASURABLE.
WHERE THE COSTS JAMES CAN USE
DATA THAN TO MAKES DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT STUDENTS NEED THOSE
HIGHER LEVELS OF KERR?
HI MY COLLEAGUES IN TALK MORE
ABOUT WELLNESS CENTERS CAN GO A
LITTLE DEEPER INTO WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH AND I THINK
WITH --
COSTER CARE TEAMS IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH THANK YOU.
WE GIVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION --
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS --
MY NAME IS LISA EISENBERG AND
THE POLICY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
ALLIANCE WERE STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION THAT PROMOTES THE
INTEGRATION OF HEALTH SERVICES
INTO SCHOOL SETTINGS AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IS A HUGE PART
OF THE WORK THAT WE DO --
SO AS I MENTIONED AS THAT AND AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID WAIT VERY
NICELY FOR ME I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS.
WHICH I THINK --
I'M BIASED I THINK IT'S A REALLY
EXCELLENT EXAMPLE.
OF WHAT CAN BE ACHIEVED WHEN
THEIR PARTNERSHIPS --
BETWEEN SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
PROVIDE AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CARE NEEDS OF STUDENTS FAMILIES
AND THEIR COMMUNITIES --
JUST TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE HEALTH CARE CLINICS
ON K. THROUGH TWELVE CAMPUSES.
THEY CAN LOOK VERY MUCH LIKE
YOUR COMMUTE YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTER OR
DOCTOR'S OFFICE WITH THE
EXCEPTION THAT THEY ARE USE
FOCUS.
STATE OFTEN ENGAGE YOUTH AND
THEIR DEVELOPMENT AND THE
SERVICES THEY PROVIDE --
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY EIGHT SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY PRIMARILY SERVE
STUDENTS IN LOW INCOME AND UNDER
RESOURCE TO COMMUNITIES --
ABOUT 70% OF OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS PROVIDE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE SERVICES
AS PART OF THEIR SPECTRUM OF
CARE.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THAT DATA
POINT IS ACTUALLY PROBABLY LOWER
THAN WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
FIELD I THINK IT CONTINUES TO
GROW TO MEET THE NEED THAT ARE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS ARE
SEEN ON THE CAMPUSES THEY SERVE.
ACTUALLY DID A LITTLE LOOK AT
OUR DATA AND THE PERCENTAGE USED
TO BE 60% OF OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS JUST FIVE YEARS
AGO WERE PROVIDING BEHAVIOR ALSO
WE'VE SEEN.
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL INCREASES IN
THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
I WAS ASKED TO DESCRIBE THE
MODEL OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS AND HOW THEY DELIVER
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND I THINK
THE BEST WAY TO DESCRIBE THEM IS
TO ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT THE THREE
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT. THREE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SPONSOR OR RUN SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS --
ABOUT HALF OF OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS ARE RUN BY
COMMUNITY HEALTH SIR HEALTH
CENTERS THESE ARE.
TYPICALLY FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS --
THAT USUALLY CO LOCATE SOME
LATER A NURSE PRACTITIONER OR
PRETTY PEDIATRICIAN.
WITH MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIANS
LICENSED CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
THESE CLINICS RARELY HAVE
CONTRACTS WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH TO DELIVER SPECIALLY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
BUT MOST OF THESE CLINICS ARE
CONTRACTED WITH MANIC MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE HEALTH PLANS SO
THEY BILL THROUGH THOSE
CONTRACTS WITH OUR MANAGED CARE.
CARE PLANS IN CALIFORNIA --
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS --
OFTEN AFFECTIONATELY REFERRED TO
AS WELLNESS CENTERS.
ARE RUN BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS WERE
ACTUALLY UNIQUE OUR STATE IS
UNIQUE IN THAT WE HAVE A HIGH
PORTION OF OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS THAT ARE RUN BY
SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
SO THESE ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT YOU TYPICALLY USE THEIR
DISTRICT GENERAL FINDS TO HIGHER
SCHOOL SOCIAL WORKERS MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY THERAPIST TO RUN.
THESE CENTERS AS SPACES ON THEIR
CAMPUS PRIMARILY TO ADDRESS THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS OF
STUDENTS.
BUT OFTEN THEY LINK TO PRIMARY
CARE AND OTHER CARE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY THE THIRD
MODEL THAT WE HAVE --
ABOUT A HANDFUL OF OUR REMAINING
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS ARE
RUN BY COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND THEY HAVE CONTRACTS
WITH THEIR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT. TO PROVIDE
SPECIALLY MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
THE DEEP DIVE INTO A LITTLE BIT
OF WHO RUNS OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF WHAT TYPE OF CARE IS
PROVIDED IN OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS I WANTED TO TALK.
VERY SIMILAR TO THE PYRAMID THAT --
MISTER LOMBARDO WAS TALKING
ABOUT GOING FROM WIDE SERVICES
ALL THE WAY UP TO THE MORE
INTENSIVE SERVICES --
IN A SCHOOL SETTING SO GOING UP
THAT PYRAMID ARE SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH CENTERS ARE DOING TEACHER
TRAINING AND TEACHER SUPPORT.
THEY ARE OFTEN TEACHING ABOUT
HOW HOW AND THERE ARE SUPPORTING
TEACHERS AND IMPLEMENTING
RESILIENCE FOCUSED.
RESTORATIVE PRACTICES IN THE
CLASSROOM HOW TO DO MINDFULNESS
PRACTICES IN THE CLASSROOM TO DE
ESCALATE STUDENTS THAT HAVE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS AS THEY
SEARCHED FOR SERVICE IN THE
CLASSROOM.
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE CONDUCTING SCHOOL
WIDE OR GRADE LEVEL SCREEN SO
THEY MAY SCREEN AN ENTIRE
STUDENT POPULATION FOR ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES OR TRAUMA
OR SUBSTANCE USE --
MANY OF OUR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS WORK WITH GROUPS OF
YOUTH LEADERS AS PURE HEALTH
EDUCATORS AS YOUTH ADVISORY
BOARDS AND THIS IS OFTEN HOW.
MANY ARE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE IMPLEMENTING USE
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID WHERE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE THERE MENTAL
HEALTH RESOURCE FOR THEIR PEERS
IN THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY.
A LOT OF OUR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE DOING GROUP THERAPY
SO THEY DO YOUNG MEN'S
EMPOWERMENT CIRCLES GRIEF GROUPS
RESTORATIVE CIRCLES --
A VARIETY OF TOPICS TO BRING
TOGETHER YOUNG PEOPLE TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES AND ADDRESS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY MANY OF OUR
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE PROVIDING ONE ON ONE
INDIVIDUAL CLINICAL THERAPY
TYPICALLY IT'S A BRIEF
INTERVENTION SO IT'S AT A
LIMITED NUMBER OF SESSIONS.
AND IF A STUDENT NEEDS ON GOING
SUPPORT THEY REFER OUT TO A
COMMUNITY PROVIDER THAT CAN BE
CO LOCATED IN THE CLINIC OR
LOCATED ON THAT SCHOOL CAMPUS SO
THAT'S A MODEL THAT WERE SEEN
GROW.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
AS ASKED TO FINISH UP I WAS
ASKED TO TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
BARRIERS AND CHALLENGES ARE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS.
ARE SO. FIFTEEN I THINK ONE OF
THE INCREDIBLE BENEFITS OF THIS
MODEL IS THAT IN LARGE PART A
LOT OF THE SERVICES ARE BILLABLE
AND THEY'RE EITHER CONTRACTING
WITH THE COUNTY.
THEIR CONTRACTING THE MEDI CAL
HEALTH PLANS --
AND THEY ARE BILLION FOR A LARGE
NUMBER OF THE CLINICAL CARE
THEY'RE PROVIDING.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE IS THAT
NOT ALL OF THE CARE THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDING IS BILLABLE SO A LOT
OF THE INCREDIBLY TRANSFORMATIVE --
INTENSIVE --
SCHOOL AIR PROVIDING IN THERE IN
THE SCHOOLS THAT THEY SERVE IS
NOT A BILLABLE SERVICE SO THAT'S
A CHALLENGE.
IS HOW TO SUSTAIN THOSE
PRACTICES.
PIGGY BACKING OFF OF THAT
CHALLENGE IS THERE'S NO STATE
FUNDING OR STATE PROGRAM OFFICE
FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU SEE ME TESTIFY YOU'VE
PROBABLY HEARD ME TALK ABOUT NOT
QUITE A BIT --
CALIFORNIA IS ACTUALLY THE ONLY
STATE I'M WITH A LARGE NUMBER OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS AND
NO STATE PROGRAM OFFICE.
AND I WOULD JUST --
CAN PIGGYBACK OFF OF MISTER
BRISCOE COMMENTS ALAMEDA COUNTY
HAS A REALLY ROBUST NETWORK OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THE COUNTY
HAS PUT UP BASE FUNDING FOR
THOSE CLINICS --
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
NETWORK STRENGTHENED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE --
OUR SCHOOL WHICH HEALTH IN A
STRUGGLE WITH COOL SCHOOL
FACILITIES AND CONFIDENTIAL
SPACES HOW DO YOU IT'S IT'S AN
INVESTMENT IT'S A SPACE ON A
CAMPUS.
THAT IS YOUTH FRIENDLY AND YOU
THINK GAUGED.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY THE LAST
BARRIER THAT.
ARE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTERS
AND SCHOOLS BY AND LARGE ARE
FACING IS THAT THEY OFTEN BECOME
THE DE FACTO RESOURCE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH WHEN UNDER INSURED OR NON
MEDI CAL STUDENTS.
CAN'T GET THE HEALTH THAT THEY
ARE ENTITLED TO IN THEIR
COMMUNITY OR FROM THEIR PRIVATE
HEALTH PLANS --
SO OFTEN ARE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE THE ONES AND THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE ONES THAT THAT
PICK UP THE PIECES WHEN THEY
CAN'T NETWORK CARE THEY CAN'T
ACCESS CARE IN THE COMMUNITY --
I'M GONNA FINISH WRAP IT UP KEEP
IT SHORT.
I I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
DESPITE THOSE BARRIERS THAT ARE
MENTIONED I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
SEEING THE NETWORK OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTERS GROW.
AND BE BECOME MORE ROBUST MORE
AND MORE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ADD ON BEHAVIORAL HEALTH%
ADD ON A FAIRLY ROBUST SPECTRUM
OF CARE IN THEIR CLINICS AND I
THINK THAT'S A TRUE.
TESTAMENT TO THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THEY'RE DOING AND COMMUNITIES
THAT'S REALLY COMMUNITY FOCUSED
USED DRIVEN --
AND ENGAGED AND AND IS
TRANSFORMING THE SCHOOL
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE SO
I'M.
VERY EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT MODEL AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AND I THINK
IT'S IT'S TRULY TRANSFORMATIVE
WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY HAD A
QUESTION.
I DO -- YOU
KNOW OBVIOUSLY THIS IS FOCUSED
ON ON THE SCHOOL SETTING SO WE
NEED TO KNOW MORE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE.
ON THE PRIVATE SIDE THROUGH
THEIR HEALTH SYSTEM WHICH DOCTOR
WITH ENGAGE WITH OUR LAST PANEL
ABOUT BUT OUT OF BETTER SCHOOLS
BACK.
IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE SO STRAPPED
THESE DAYS AND CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL WHY SERVE ON THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ARRESTING
SCHOOL FUNDING WHICH I CHAIR AND
NO WE HAD SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD
BE RIGHT HERE IN THE CITY
SACRAMENTO WHICH ARE.
ON THE VERGE OF GOING BANKRUPT
AND HAVING THE STATE.
TAKEOVER SO --
OUR DISTRICTS MAKING THESE
DECISIONS TO INVEST IN THESE
SERVICES WHEN.
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER.
IN IN THEIR EYES AND THEIR CBO
SIZE IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND AND ARE
WE SEEING THE ARE WE SEEING THE
OPPOSITE I WAS SEEING A DECREASE
FROM DISTRICTS.
OFFER THESE PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THEY NEEDED USE THEIR EIGHTY
SAID EARLIER USING THEIR KIND OF
GENERAL FUND.
DISCRETIONARY DOLLARS ARE.
ARE THOSE BEING MORE AND MORE
USED TO JUST KEEP THE DISTRICT.
OF LOS.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I MEAN I
I WOULD SAY THAT WE'RE SEEING
MORE AND MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
INTERESTED IN BUILDING OUT
WELLNESS CENTERS WHICH IF THINK
WE SWEETIE STRUGGLE AS A STATE
ASSOCIATION TO DEFINE WHETHER
THOSE ARE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
CENTERS ARE NOT I THINK.
THAT WE WOULD INCLUDE THEM IN
OUR BIG UMBRELLA --
BUT I THINK IT'S OFTEN A LOWER
BAR TO BRING IN AND DEVELOP A
WELLNESS CENTER OUTSIDE OF A
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER.
I THINK --
SO WE'RE SEEN THE NEEDS GROW AND
WERE SEEN AND CONTINUED
INVESTMENT IN IN THIS MODEL IN
THE SCHOOL BASED HEALTH CENTER
MODEL HOW THEY'RE DOING THAT
LOOKS DIFFERENT IN EVERY
COMMUNITY.
OFTEN.
I I THINK IT.
BOILS DOWN TO PARTNERSHIPS
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS OFTEN
HAVE --
ACCESS GRANTS WHERE THEY CAN
APPLY -- FOR
ACCESS GRANTS TO BUILD SPACES TO
PROVIDE MORE CARE SO IF A SCHOOL
DISTRICT CAN BRING IN A PARTNER
THAT CAN.
THAT LEVERAGE THOSE RESOURCES
THEY HAVE THAN THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOESN'T HAVE TO DIP
INTO THEIR SCHOOL DISTRICT
FUNDING --
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE BILLION LEN
MEDI CAL AND REINVESTING THOSE
DOLLARS IN SCHOOL HEALTH SUPPORT
I THINK WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS UNDERSTAND
THAT.
TO DRAW DOWN MORE FUNDING FROM
THE STATE THEIR ATTENDANTS TO
DRAW DOWN THOSE DOLLARS THEY
HAVE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
UNDERLYING BARRIERS THAT KEEP
STUDENTS OUT OF SCHOOL --
BUT YES.
YELL DISTRICTS ARE CHALLENGED
WITH CHALLENGING DECISIONS AND
YOU SEE SOMETIMES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE A BUDGET FOR THE
SERVICES AND FOR EXAMPLE.
LIKE POLICE SERVICES PUBLIC
SAFETY WHETHER SCHOOL RESOURCE
OFFICERS AND THERE'S DEBATES
WILL ALSO YOU HAVE A SQUAD CAR
SITTING OUT FRONT OR SHOULD YOU
USE THOSE RESOURCES TO HIRE --
TO MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
IN THE CLASSROOM AND AND I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THE PUBLIC SAFETY
MENTAL HEALTH DEBATE AS THIS
FRONT CENTER TODAY LOS ANGELES
DEVOTED TO NOT DO IT COUNTY JAIL
AND USE THAT MONEY FOR A MENTAL
HEALTH --
PROGRAM SO I WAS SITTING IN
EXAMPLES OF WHERE.
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE I
THINK YOU KNOW WHAT MAYBE WE
DON'T NEED AT A THIRD SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICER.
CAN USE THAT MONEY FOR MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES OR SCHOOL
COUNSELORS.
I THINK WE ARE WE WE DO A LOT OF
DEEP DIVE WORK IN WEST CONTRA
COSTA AS AN EXAMPLE I CAN I CAN
ONLY PULL IT OUT EXAMPLES WHERE
WE DO.
PRETTY INTENSIVE WORK IN WERE
SEEN THAT THAT CONVERSATION PLAY
OUT THEY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
INVEST SOME OF THEIR SCHOOL
DISTRICT AHLERS IN THEIR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH CENTER SCHOOL
HEALTH NETWORK SO.
THEY ARE NEARLY DIRECTING IT
FROM THERE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN SAY THIS
EVERY YEAR REDIRECTING IT BUT
THERE IS THAT CONVERSATION THAT
THEY ARE HAPPY IN IN THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT FINANCING
DOLLARS I COULD.
DO I COULD REACH OUT TO OUR
FIELD AND STATION PLAYING OUT ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THINK IT REQUIRES --
INTEGRATED CONVERSATION AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND MYSTERY ON WAS
HEADED THAT DIRECTION IN HIS
CONVERSATION IT REQUIRES THAT
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
OUR OUR STATE IN EACH COUNTY IN
EACH DISTRICT.
THAT COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SOCIAL SERVICES PROBATION LAW
ENFORCEMENT WORK TOGETHER WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO DESIGN A
MODEL THAT WORKS WITH. FOR THAT
DISTRICT FOR THEIR COUNTY BUT
THEIR BRAIDS AS DOLLARS TOGETHER
THE COMPLEXITY OF MENTAL HEALTH --
FUND AND MEDICAID MEDICARE I'LL
FIND IN.
IS SO UNIQUE IN EACH COUNTY AND
APPROACHED IN DIFFERENT WAYS BY
EACH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTOR
I THINK YOU'LL HEAR THAT FROM
DOCTOR MILLER.
THAT.
IT REALLY DOES REQUIRE THAT
INTEGRATED --
SYSTEM TO PROBLEM SOLVE AND LOOK
AT HOW ARE WE GOING TO SUPPORT
OUR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IF IT
MEANS HAVING A WELLNESS CENTER
HEALTH CENTERS THE BEST
MENTALITY.
BUT LET IN THAT LOCAL COMMUNITY.
FIGURE OUT THE RESOURCES AND HOW
THEY DESIGNED THE RESOURCES AND
I I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO UNDER
HEALTHCARE REFORM INCLUDED --
ARE HM US IN THAT CONVERSATION
AM DOCTOR MILLER AGAIN WILL GO
AND AND GREATER DEPTH ABOUT THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF HMO IS A
RESPONSIBILITIES --
COUNTY AND MEDICARE NOW FUND
THEN BUT IF THOSE AGENCIES ARE
NOT ALL WORKING TOGETHER.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SPENT AND MORE
MONEY LESS EFFECTIVE LAKE.
AND IN OUR VIEW CLASS OR STARTED
TO PAUL FAMILIES APART BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO GO TO DIFFERENT
PLACES TO GET THE PROVISION OF
THOSE SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
AND I WOULD CAUTION ANY SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR REMOVING SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS FROM ANY
CAMPUS BECAUSE THEIR NECESSARY
ELEMENT OF STUDENTS A I CAMERA
CAMPUS OF FIVE THOUSAND THAT'S
LARGER THAN SOME CITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT THERE POLICE
OFFICERS LOOK AROUND OUR
BUILDING.
FULL POLICE OFFICERS SO I JUST
BE CAREFUL I THINK THEY ARE
NECESSARY ELEMENT.
IN IMMEDIATE STUDENT SAFETY WHEN
WHEN EVENTS GO SOUTH --
SINGLE FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LOMBARDO MISS
EISENBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE MOVED TO OUR THIRD AND
FINAL PANEL --
WHICH WILL DISCUSS THE SUCCESSES
AND CHALLENGES IN SCHOOL AND
COUNTY AGENCY PARTNERSHIPS.
AMY MILLER FROM THE MONTEREY
COUNTIES BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCY
AND JACK.
WELL AS FOR A LESSON FROM THE
HUMBLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WILL JOIN US AND I
THINK THIS IS REALLY WHERE I WAS
GOING EARLIER SO FEEL FREE.
TO PONTIFICATE ON THIS TOPIC IS
AND HOW ARE THESE.
ARE THESE RELATIONSHIPS BILL HOW
DO WE MAKE THIS WORK WE KNOW THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD THAT DEFINE
SEEN SOME EXAMPLES AND HA HA HOW
DO YOU DO THIS THE IDEA MAKE IT
HAPPEN DAY ONE WHAT DO YOU DO
THANK YOU.
THIS -- ONE
SO I HAVE A HAND UP A DEVELOP
FOR THE COMMITTEE I HOPE YOU
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU BECAUSE ONE
OF THE THINGS I THINK SYSTEM
RESPONSIBLE FOR SOME PREVENTION
WORK.
THE MILD MODERATE BUT THE HEALTH
PLANS ARE STILL IN CHARGE OF THE
MILES WHICH I KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTED SPECTRUM IS GREEN --
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR WORKING
WITH HUMANS MIGHT KNOW THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO SAY WHO IS
MILD WHOSE MODERATE AND IN OUR
BUSINESS MODEL WE'RE SERVING
QUITE A BIT.
OF THE MILD POPULATION ARE
SCHOOL BASED INTEGRATION EFFORTS.
SO IN MY COUNTY WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS WE'VE PARTNERED WITH LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
TO TAKE THEIR EL CAP MONEY SO
THEIR LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
CONTROL MONEY AND THEY INVEST
THAT -- IN
GIVING THE MONEY TO US THROUGH
AND USE AND THEN WE PULL DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDING IS A MATCH.
FOOT SO FOR VERY HIGH POVERTY
SCHOOLS WE DO IT INITIALLY BASED
ON THE FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
NUMBERS THEY PAY --
A SMALL FRACTION YOU MIGHT KNOW
THE WAY THAT MEDI CAL WORKS AS
EACH KID HAS AN EIGHT COAT.
AND THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE CAN
BE AS HIGH AS NINETY SEVEN CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR.
PEOPLE DOWN A LOT OF FEDERAL
MONEY AND THEN WE JUST CHARGE
THE SCHOOL FOR THE REMAINDER
THAT'S ON COVERED USING THEIR AL
CAPP MONEY.
AND NOT SYSTEM HAS BEEN REALLY
SUCCESSFUL RULES --
PEOPLE THIS COMMITTEE MIGHT
REMEMBER THAT COUNTY BEAVER
HEALTH USED TO BE IN CHARGE OF
DOING THE I EP RELATED SERVICES --
THERE'S A LEGISLATIVE CHANGE
OVER FIVE YEARS AGO WHERE MOST
COUNTIES BROKE UP IN OUR COUNTY
WE NEVER GOT DIVORCED STAY
TOGETHER.
KIND OF SAY WE WENT TO MARRIAGE
COUNSELLING DID A LOT AND USE.
AND THROUGH THAT THAT'S WHERE WE
DEVELOP THAT IDEA AROUND TAKING
THAT LOCAL EL CAP DOLLARS AND
GET INTO KIDS BEFORE THEY HAVE
AN IGP.
IGP IS NOT THE BEST TIME TO
INTERVENE WITH THE KIDS THEY
ALREADY HAVE A PROBLEM.
SO WE REALLY WORKED TO DEVELOP
KIND OF THE INTERCONNECTED
SYSTEMS FRAMEWORK WE USE SOME
INNOVATION DOLLARS SO KIND OF
FROM TOBY SHOP --
AN HSA INNOVATION DOLLARS
INITIALLY FUNDED --
FIGURING OUT HOW TO DO P. I. S.
WHICH REALLY TAUGHT US HOW TO BE
IN THE SCHOOLS BECAUSE OF THEIR
CULTURE AND INTERVENE AS EARLY
AS POSSIBLE --
AND REALLY DEVELOP STRATEGIES
FOR THE COMMISSION SO WE HAVEN'T
SCHOOLS THAT ARE MORE PRIMARY
PREVENTION SO DOING SOME GROUP
WORK.
SOME WORK ON SCHOOL CULTURE AND
SCHOOL CLIMATE AND THEN BEING
ABLE TO RESPONSE TO THE VERY
HIGH NEEDS KIDS WHICH ON YOUR
DIAGRAM HERE I KIND OF SHOWS ARE
A TIER.
THREE SO OUR GOAL IN THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH SCHOOLS IS TO
PROVIDE AS COST EFFECTIVE
SERVICES AS POSSIBLE.
THE VALUE PROPOSITION I THINK
THAT WE BRING TO THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM IS AGAIN LEADING TEACHERS
BE TEACHERS I THINK THEY DESERVE
THAT THAT'S A HARD ENOUGH JOB --
AND THEN WE WE COMMENDED
BEHAVIOR ALL SPECIALISTS.
AND OUR CLINICIANS ARE TRAINED
OF TRAINING A BIG INVESTMENT
REALLY TO RESPOND TO WHAT MIGHT
BE A MILD DEPRESSION ALL THE WAY
UP TO A KID THAT BECAUSE OF AN
I. P. HAS TO BE PLACED OUTSIDE
OF THAT COUNTY --
INTO A RESIDENTIAL PLACEMENT
FACILITY --
AND THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK THAT ISOLATED SCHOOL
COUNSELORS CAN DO SO SOME OTHER
BUSINESS MODELS THAT EXIST --
THAT PEOPLE ARE IMPLEMENTING ITS
MORE SCHOOLS HIRING THERAPISTS.
BUT WE REALLY SEE THE VALUE IN
HAVING AN INTEGRATED SCHOOL TEAM.
SO WE CAN INVEST IN KIND OF BALK
TRAINING AND REALLY LOOKING
CLOSELY AT THE QUALITY QUALITY
CONTROL THE SERVICES PROVIDED --
AND THEN ALL THAT ARDUOUS MEDI
CAL BILLING THAT WE LOVE TO HATE.
MY TEAM DOES THAT AND THE
SCHOOLS JUST REALLY --
PAYING THE DIFFERENCE SO I THINK
IT BRINGS A LOT MORE MONEY INTO
MY COMMUNITY WHICH IS A BIG DEAL
PEOPLE THINK OF MONTEREY COUNTY
AND PROBABLY YOU THOUGHT OF
PEBBLE BEACH.
BUT THAT'S NOT REALLY WHERE THE
ACTION IS --
WE HAVE A A VERY HIGH LEVEL OF
POVERTY IN OUR AGRICULTURAL
REGION --
AND THAT'S THAT'S THE GROUP THAT
WERE RESPONDING TO I THINK THIS
COMMITTEE SHOULD BE THINKING
ABOUT THE PRIVATE INSURANCE
NETWORK.
THOUGH BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE
REALLY DEVELOPED A MODEL IT'S
YOU CAN BE AN EXPENSIVE MODEL
WHEN YOU HAVE THE COST CARS --
AND ALL THE TRAINING THAT THEY
HAVE.
BUT WE DON'T SEE THAT THE
PRIVATE INSURANCE NETWORK IS
PROVIDING THAT THE MORE FLUENT
SCHOOLS -- I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF A MARKET
FAILURE IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S A LOT OF ANALYSIS TO DO TO
LOOK AT WHAT SORTS OF STAFFING
THAT THE PRIVATE INSURANCE
NETWORK SHOULD BE INVESTING IN
IN SCHOOLS WE KNOW IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
RIGHT SO.
PEOPLE ALWAYS SAY WE WANT TO
COME TO ANDREAS YEAR PROGRAM.
SO YOU CAN BUT THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING TO SEE IT'S THEIR BEST
SOMETIMES IN CLOSETS RIGHT.
IT'S BEGINNING A RELATIONSHIP
EVENTUALLY THEY THEY GET ENOUGH
STEAM TO GET AN OFFICE.
BUT WE'RE NOT WEARING BADGES
THAT SAY --
MENTAL HEALTH YOU GUYS
UNDERSTAND THE SCARCITY OF
SCHOOL SPACE --
WERE NOT WEARING BADGES THE SAME
MENTAL HEALTH ARE AT THE JOB OF
OUR THERAPIST IS TO INTEGRATE
INTO THE SCHOOL CLIMATE CULTURES
THERE'S NOT STIGMA ABOUT --
IF SOMEONE'S.
GET ENGAGING IN THERAPEUTIC
SERVICES OR ANYTHING THEY'RE
WEARING SCHOOL BADGES AND
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE EATING
LUNCH WITH TEACHERS IN THE BREAK
ROOM RIGHT SO UNDERSTANDING SOME
OF THE STUDENTS DOING
CONSULTATION ABOUT KIDS THAT
THEY'RE STARTING TO NOTICE
PROBLEMS WITH. TO THINK ABOUT
YOU KNOW THAT EARLY EXPOSURE TO
TRAUMA SERVICES TO ME ARE
UNEQUIVOCALLY THE RIGHT THING TO
DO WHEN I FIRST STARTED MY JOB I
SAID IF I HAD A MAGIC WAND I
WOULD PUT ALL OF MY CHILDREN
SERVICES AND SCHOOLS.
I DON'T HAVE A MAGIC WAND I HAVE
SOMETIMES THE NUMBER ONE YOUTH
HOMICIDE RATES I CAN'T CUT MY
JUVENILE JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO INVEST MORE IN SCHOOL
SO I'M VERY THANKFUL THAT YOU
KNOW.
OUR COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
IS REALLY PARTNERED SHOWN
LEADERSHIP AND ENCOURAGE SCHOOLS
TO INVEST IN US I THINK WE'RE
SEEING HUGE DIVIDENDS.
SINCE WE IMPLEMENT OUR PROGRAM
WHERE.
WE'RE DOING THAT AL CAPP MONEY
WE'VE INCREASED THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS SERVED BY 158% --
AND SO MANY THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT ON
NEVER BE ABLE TO REPORT SHE WAS
OUTCOMES RIGHT.
SO IT'S I'LL NEVER BE ABLE TO
REPORT TO YOU HOW MANY TIMES
I'VE HAD STUDENTS THREATEN TO
HARM OTHERS WERE WE'VE INTERVENE
EARLY BECAUSE THERE ARE YOU KNOW
pWERE GETTING INFORMATION.
AND GETTING THAT KID INTO CARE I
THINK THE PROGRAM IS JUST REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVEIN TRULY SAVING
LIVES -- I
WISH THAT MORE COUNTIES WERE
KIND OF AFFORDED THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THIS ALL SAY THAT I THINK
THE THING THAT'S MADE THIS
POSSIBLE.
IS REALLY THE RELATIONSHIP IN
INVESTMENTS I KNOW IT THERE'S AN
EDUCATOR ON THE PANEL TODAY --
EACH SCHOOLS A DIFFERENT CULTURE
RIGHT AND IN MY COMMUNITY
THERE'S TREMENDOUS DIVERSITY
BEING KIND OF A LARGE GEOGRAPHIC
COUNTY.
SO WE HAVE A FULL TIME MANAGER
THAT REALLY INVEST IN DEVELOPING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH EACH SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION --
AND RESPONDING TO AND HELPING
THEM WORK THROUGH PROBLEMS THAT
THEY'VE GOT A REALLY DIFFICULT I
E. P. WAS IT A LITIGIOUS FAMILY.
MORE IN THERE IT KIND OF A HIGH
LEVEL TRYING TO HELP THE SCHOOL
FIGURE IT OUT.
WERE ALSO DOING REALLY IMPORTANT
TRAININGS AROUND TEACHER BURN
OUT WE'RE DOING TRAININGS FOR
TEACHERS ON MINDFULNESS IN THE
CLASSROOM HOW THEY CAN IMPLEMENT
MEDITATION IN THE KINDERGARTEN
TYPESETTING WHICH JUST KIND OF A
SORT OF ONE OF OUR ADDITIVE
SERVICES BEYOND JUST IS THAT WE
PROVIDE.
IT'S PRETTY ADORABLE TO SEE A
ROOM FULL OF FIVE YEAR OLDS
MEDITATING.
NO ONE'S LOSING IN THAT
SITUATION.%
SO -- THAT'S
REALLY THE THE KEY POINTS THAT I
WANTED TO SAY IS YOU KNOW THE
OVERALL BUSINESS MODEL --
THERE'S JUST SO IMPORTANT TO LET
TEACHERS WE REALLY GET TO BE
TEACHERS AND INVESTING COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH EVEN OUR FUNDING
IS COMPLICATED YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALL EXCITED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
PAYMENT REFORM AND WHAT THAT
WILL DO.
I THINK THE FUTURE IS REALLY
TRANSFORMATIVE SYSTEM OR WE GET
RID OF THAT PAPERWORK BURDEN.
AND THEN MY THERAPIST THAT ARE
IN THE SCHOOLS I COULD GET 30%
MORE PRODUCTIVITY FROM THEM IF I
COULD GET RID OF SOME OF THOSE
DOCUMENTATION STANDARDS --
ALL SAY THAT YOU KNOW AS A
BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM WE
ENCOURAGE LITTLE BIT OF RISK.
BECAUSE WE'RE SERVING UP PRETTY
BROAD DEFINITION OF WHO WHO WE
HAVE IN OUR SYSTEM BECAUSE
TECHNICALLY IT'S SOME OF THESE
KIDS SHOULD BE SENT OVER TO THE
MANAGED CARE PLANS --
Và HAVEN'T QUITE DEVELOP THE
NETWORK TO MEET THEIR NEEDS.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
WE EXPERIENCE IN THIS
COLLABORATION AND MAYBE WHY --
SOME CANDIES HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO MAKE THAT STRATEGIC
INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
PROACTIVE OBVIOUSLY.
A FIVE YEAR OLDS DOING
MEDITATION HER.
MISTER MISTER KILEY RIVERS YOGA.
HELLO BUT IT.
MISTER ROSS.
BY GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JACK PEARL
SI BUCKS FORMER --
KATE TEACHER DOWN IN THE BAY
AREA AND THEN MOVE BACK TO HOME --
COUNTY IN NINETY SIX WHERE I'M
FROM WAS HIGH SCHOOL HISTORY
TEACHER.
I FEEL UNDERPREPARED --
BEGIN ADMINISTRATOR AND I DO ANY
NUMBER OF THINGS I'M ARE
HOMELESS AND FOSTER YOUTH
LIAISON CAREER TECHNICAL LEAD --
YESTERDAY I HAD A PHONE CALL
ABOUT DUAL ENROLLMENT WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OVER LOCAL
INDIAN TRIBES.
AND THAT --
WAS ON THE PHONE WITH THE
SUICIDE PREVENTION TEAM FROM
STANFORD AND GOT TO FOR THERE'S
NATIVE AMERICAN HEALTH SERVICE
AND I DROVE SIX HOURS DOWN HERE
BECAUSE WE ARE ROLE IN FACT --
BUT DON'T THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING YOUR BRIEFLY HUMBOLDT
COUNTY WITH EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS GIVE OR
TAKE WE HAVE THIRTY TWO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE LOOK TO THE BALKANS
AN ORGANIZATIONAL UNIT MODEL AND
I WOULD ARGUE WE PROBABLY.
IT'S WITH FIFTEEN OR SO
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLES I WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE WITH MY
SUPERINTENDENT WITH SIXTEEN
HUNDRED KIDS WERE BY HUMBLE
COUNTY STANDARDS A LARGE
DISTRICT --
HE WAS ACTUALLY DRIVING A VAN
BECAUSE ONE OF OUR KEY AIDES WHO
WE PROVIDE SERVICES FOR HIS BUS
DRIVER WAS SICK AND SO MY
SUPERINTENDENT MISSED MY MEETING
BECAUSE HE WAS PICKING UP
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL KIDS.
THAT'S RURAL SCHOOLS --
OR WE IN CALIFORNIA THE EUROPE
TRIED AND THE WHO BY VALLEY TRY
OUR ACES NUMBERS ARE.
TERRIBLE AS A GRANT WRITER RICH
SOMETIMES ADVANTAGEOUS BUT OVER
30% OF OUR GROWN UPS --
SORRY THAT ELEMENTARY BACKGROUND
30% OF OUR ADULTS REPORT OVER
FOR MORE ACES AND ANECDOTALLY
YOU GOING TO OUR CLASSROOMS YOU
TALK TO OUR TEACHERS IT.
CAR CARE PROVIDERS.
A SOLID THIRD OF OUR KIDS ARE
THE FACT THAT COMES SCHOOL IN
THE MORNING YOU JUST WANNA HUG I
MEAN IT'S ASTOUNDING WHAT THEY
DO.
ARE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY KIDS
SURVEY --
CINNAMON --
KILEY --
SPOKE I THINK STATEWIDE
PERCENTAGE OF KIDS WITH SUICIDE
IDEATION WAS ABOUT SIXTEEN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS FRANKLY THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY --
22% OF OUR KIDS INDICATED IN
LAST YEAR'S SURVEY THAT THEY HAD
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERED THAT DURING
THE PAST YEAR --
BEING RURAL THERE IS A SHORTAGE
OVERALL SHORTAGE OF MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
DISTANCE IS A REAL THING.
IT WAS FUNNY WHEN I TAUGHT IT
SAME BIRDS IN OAKLAND WE CAN
JUMP ON THE BUS AND MAKE TWO
TRANSFERS AND LO AND BEHOLD I
WAS AT THE OAKLAND MUSEUM.
IF I WAS TEACHING ELEMENTARY IN
MCKINLEY THE WORD DISTRICT
OFFICES.
I MIGHT HAVE TO WAIT TWO HOURS
TO GET THE ONE BUS THAT THREE OR
FOUR HOURS SECTION TO GO TO OUR
CLERK HISTORY MUSEUM AND BRING
MY KIDS THERE AND TURN AROUND
AND BRING THEM BACK. FIFTY TWO
MINUTES LATER BECAUSE THAT'S HOW
IT WORKS TRANSPORTATION IS
DIFFICULT IF A FAMILY MEMBER
ASSUMING HERE SHE USUALLY --
SHE CAN GET TIME OFF FROM WORK
AND THEN.
GET THEIR KIDS TO THE COUNSELING
APPOINTMENT IN EUREKA IT'S EVEN
NOT ONLY FIFTEEN MILES IT'S A
DIFFICULTY IN SO WE TO BE
MINDFUL OF THAT YOU KNOW OVER
THREE FOUR HUNDRED OF OUR
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE ARE RURAL
DISTRICTS --
WE WE OFTEN LACK THE CAPACITY TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
NON FORTUNATE MY DISTRICT YOURS
AGO MADE THE COMMITMENT WE HAVE
A STUDENTS SYSTEMS COUNSELOR AT
THE ARCADE A HIGH CAMPUS SITE
BUT LEVIN HUNDRED KIDS.
AND THE MECHANICAL CAMPUS SITE
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND AND WHAT
THAT'S A COMMITMENT WE MADE.
WE DON'T HAVE AN EXTRA SCIENCE
TEACHER WE DON'T HAVE A THIS OR
THAT BECAUSE WE MADE THAT
COMMITMENT AND IN WILD YOU KNOW
PEOPLE LOVE TO COME TO BE AND
SAY WE'VE GOT EL CAP MONEY WE
HAVE THIS MONEY.
YES BUT YOU KNOW OUR STIRS
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE GOING UP ONE
AND A HALF PERCENT EVERY YEAR
AND YOU KNOW EVERY TIME I TALK
TO MY BUSINESS MANAGER I HAVE TO
HUNGER AND SAKE.
SEEMED IT'LL BE OKAY WILL WE WE
WILL STAY IN THE BLACK SOMEHOW
IN THE FUTURE IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW
IS THE CATHOLIC AND IT'S AN
ACTIVE.
ACTIVE FAITH ARE ONLY MYSTERY
BUT WE'LL WORK IT OUT I PROMISE
YOU.
NURSING IS IN SHORT SUPPLY WE
HAVE MY DISTRICT HAS ONE SCHOOL
NURSE. TO SITES SIX SEVEN MILES
APART.
AND WE'RE ACTUALLY THE MOST WELL
STAFFED NURSING SYSTEM ERROR
DISTRICT IN THE COUNTY OUR
ELEMENTARY DISTRICT IS ELEVEN
HUNDRED KIDS THREE SCHOOLS.
A WEEKNURSES WHO GOES AND DOES
REQUIRE TESTING ONE DAY ON ONE
SCHOOL THEN THE NEXT THE NEXT.
YOU KNOW THEN WHO IS THE WHO IS
PROVIDING THE SERVICES.
THE OFFICE LADIES AND SO THERE
ARE CHALLENGES AND WE'RE NOT --
IN AND LAKE WILL BE GONE SPECIAL
ED IN THE STATE AND 20% OF OUR
KIDS ARE ON AYE EP'S NOW IN MY
DISTRICT.
THE VAST MAJORITY COME TO US
ALREADY IN THE SYSTEM THERE
MOSTLY IDENTIFIED BY FIFTH GRADE
AND AS I LOOKED INTO IT AND
WORKED IN THE SIX PEOPLE.
A SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE THOSE
KIDS ARE GOING IN BECAUSE OF
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES --
TALKED ABOUT WITH THE TEACHERS
DO WITH THE TEACHERS WANT TO DO
IT OUT OF SPRINT ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL IN EUREKA.
THREATEN FIFTY KIDS --
MY FRIEND WAS IN THERE DOING
OBSERVATION RECENTLY IN THIS
WONDERFUL FIRST GRADE TEACHER IS
BUSY TEACHING A CLASS WITH THE
LITTLE BOY WHO WOULD BE A TOP OF
THE PYRAMID HERE KIND OF GET.
LITERALLY SHE HAS BOTH ARMS
AROUND AND SOME LITTLE GIRL NEXT
TO THEIR IS TURNING THE BOOK SO
THEY CAN READ ALOUD FOR THE
CLASS BECAUSE IF SHE LET HIM GO.
HE WAS GOING TO START DISRUPTING
THE CLASS AND SHE GOT WHAT SHE
WANTS AND THE OFFICE THEY'D BEEN
TRADED MULTI TIER SYSTEM TO
SUPPORT THIS IS A PPO SCHOOL
THAT WITH HIGH FIDELITY.
THIS CHILD NEEDS SOMETHING MORE
AND YOU KNOW.
IT'S NOT THAT BEING SAID SAW BAD
NEWS WE ARE FORTUNATE WE HAVE
REALLY OVER THE LAST FOUR FIVE
YEARS ESPECIALLY IN THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF OR SO.
STARTED TO MODEL THIS
INTERAGENCY COOPERATION THAT MS
MILLER THAT WAS TALKING ABOUT
THAT MICHAEL TALKED ABOUT IN THE
LAST.
PANEL THERE WHERE WE ARE TALKING
TO EACH OTHER THEIR CHALLENGES
THOUGH --
MISTER --
MISBEHAVE.
THERE'S A THERE'S A BACKRONYM
THE USING ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR A
MULTI DISCIPLINARY TEAM WE CALL
THE STUDENT ASSISTANCE TEAM
WHERE I'M FROM BUT IF.
I'M IN THE STUDENT SYSTEMS TEAM
OF MY DISTRICT AND SOMEBODY THE
RELEASE OF INFORMATION TO TALK
TO A STUDENT ABOUT THEM IN HIS.
FOR BOB ARE MAKING IT HARDER FOR
US TO SHARE INFORMATION TO HELP
KIDS AND I KNOW YOU'RE THE ALL
MIGHTY POWERFUL --
SIMPLY COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
STRUCTURE YOU CAN WAVE A MAGIC
WAND SHELLACKING APPARENTLY --
TO OF TO BUT THAT THAT'S A
LEGITIMATE CONCERN HOW CAN WE
KNOW WHY CAN'T WE TALK TO BREAK
DOWN SILOS IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT --
ARE COUNTY MIDDLE SERVICE TRIAGE
GRANT WE WERE FORTUNATE WERE ONE
OF FOR THE STATE TO GET IT FIVE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS OVER --
FOR YEARS.
THAT'S A SIGNIFICANT SUM OF
MONEY WE'VE INTENTIONALLY.
BROKEN IT UP ACROSS THE REGION'S
BECAUSE WE'RE SO BALKANIZED SO
MY REGION. THIRTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TWELVE THIRTEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICT SIX THOUSAND KIDS WITH
FULL TIME CLINICIAN WE HAVE TO
DISTRICT EMPLOYED.
CASE CARRIERS OR SUPPORT
PROVIDERS BUT THAT'S FOR SIX
THOUSAND IN IF ONLY 1% OF THOSE
KIDS ARE AT THAT HIGHEST HIGHEST
LEVEL THAT SIXTY WELL ACCORDING
I'M NOT A I'M A HISTORY TEACHER
BY TRAINING BUT I'M TOLD THAT'S
ALMOST TWICE REGULAR CASELOAD
NOT TO MENTION THE FACT THAT.
FROM WORK TO GREEN POINT IS AN
HOUR AND FORTY ABOUT AN HOUR
TWENTY MINUTE DRIVE SO WE DON'T
WANT THESE PEOPLE SPENDING TIME
IN CARS WE DO WANT THEM.
AT THE AT THE SCHOOL AS FOR
STARTING TO HAVE COMMON
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
DECEMBER ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOLKS FROM COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH.
CHILD WELFARE PROBATION SOME OF
LOCAL TRIBES OTHERS CAME IN AND
LEARNED ABOUT THE AYE YOU THE
MAGIC OF THE IEP PROCESS AND HOW
WE IDENTIFY KIDS STARTING FOR
INSTANCE WITH A STUDENT STUDY
TEAM WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP THIS
CHILD BEFORE WE GET THE MANY
WHEN I EAT P. --
ON THE TWENTY SIXTH OF THIS
MONTH YOU'RE ALL INVITED BUT UP
MONTH COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH AND
THOSE FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING FOR THOSE OF US IN THE
SCHOOLS.
WHAT IT IS HOW IT WORKS WITH
THEM SO THAT INSTEAD OF US JUST
CALLING SWITCHBOARD AND NOT
KNOWING WHAT TO SAY WILL START
TO MAKE THOSE CONNECTIONS SO
THERE IS A WAY? TO DO THIS --
CHAU JUST LIKE WE SAID YOU KNOW
THE INFORMATION IS --
SHARING SOMETHING.
. CARD TIME IS AN ISSUE SO THE
IDEA OF TELL US LIKE HIGH TREE
OR TELEHEALTH I THINK ONCE A KID
GETS TO KNOW SOMEBODY.
THERE IS A WAY TO DO THAT WHERE
SOMEBODY CAN ACTUALLY REACHING
OUT TO THESE FAR FLUNG SCHOOLS.
MY GOOD FRIEND IS THE PRINCIPAL
SUPERINTENDENT BUS DRIVER LEAD
TEACHER OF A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR
SIX KIDS --
SO EVEN IF THEY IF THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
QUALIFY EVEN IF THEY'RE ALL.
LIKE YOU TO MEDI CAL TO SUPPORT
A PROVIDER BUT THERE COULD VERY
WELL BE ONE OR TWO KIDS THERE
WHO MIGHT NEED HELP AND I WAS IN
A MEETING WITH THE TWELVE
SMALLEST DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
PRINCIPLES IN THE COUNTY THAT
ANYBODY UNDER KIDS I ASKED HIM
THIS QUESTION BECAUSE I KNEW.
WAS COMING HERE'S A BE VERY
CONSERVATIVE HOW MANY OF YOUR
KIDS NEED AS AND I I'M NOT A
CLINICIAN I DON'T NOTICES BUT
PSYCHIATRIC LEVEL HELP AND I
SAID SHOW ME SHOW FIGURES AS IT
AND DON'T GO CRAZY DON'T TELL ME
FOURTEEN FOR YOUR FORTY KIDS.
TWENTY EIGHT FINGERS WENT UP --
MULTIPLE PEOPLE MIND YOU BUT BUT
IT DOES FOR EIGHT HUNDRED KIDS
IN IF YOU DO THE MATH THAT'S
ABOUT THREE AND A HALF PERCENT.
WHICH P. B. I. S. MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS IT'S SO WHENEVER GUARDS
PLUS WE WERE NOT FAR ABOVE
AVERAGE BUT HOW DO YOU SERVE
TWENTY EIGHT KIDS IN. THIRTEEN
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SITES OVER AN
AREA THAT IS APPROACHING THE
SIZE OF LA COUNTY IT IS A
CHALLENGING SO WE NEED TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND NUMBER.
AND ALL THAT ALL STOP RIGHT
THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE DISTRICT
DOES NOT JUST THE COMMENTS WERE
I'M WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU IN
HUMBOLDT COUNTY MISTER BROWN --
JUST THE ENERGY WITH WHICH YOU
APPROACH THIS AND AND THE THE
ATTITUDE OF COURSE GOING TO
FRONT FIGURE IT OUT --
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
PEOPLE --
OFTEN DON'T REALIZE IT IN A LOT
OF RURAL COUNTIES WE HAVE A LOT
MORE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE IS
LOS ANGELES HAS ELLIE UST.
HOW MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS TOTAL
IN HUMBLE COUNTY? THIRTY TWO
YEAH.
AND WE HAVE ALMOST FORTY AND HOW
AND CINEMA COUNTY AND AND AND
AND YOU KNOW YOU HAD THE OTHER
THREE COUNTIES I REPRESENT AND A
LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF THE
LID.
SO THE THE CHALLENGES IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES ARE YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE THE GRANT WRITERS ALL
THE TIME THEY'RE DOING A LOT OF
THESE THINGS AND AND TRYING TO
PULL ALWAYS RESOURCES TOGETHER
IS REALLY DIFFICULT SO --
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF YOUR
EFFORTS AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ESPECIALLY FOR BEING HERE TODAY
MY VOICE.
GREAT THANK YOU AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION COULD OR
SHOULD.
COME AND WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
ESTABLISHING A MENTAL HEALTH.
AND SO THIS CONVERSATIONS ARE
ARE ON ONLY NOW.
THANK YOU OF AN VERY PROACTIVE
APPROACH APPRECIATE THANK YOU
FOR SURE --
WITH THAT --
I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR SPEAKERS
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
THEY'VE TRAVELED FROM AROUND THE
STATE TO SHARE THEIR THEIR
EXPERIENCES.
UNOPENED HEARING FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT A STEP TO THE MICROPHONE
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF YOUR
ORGANIZATION I'M OF YOUR REMARKS
TWO ONE MINUTE AT THE MICROPHONE
PLEASE.
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
REMARKS FOR ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
AND IT SHOULD SAY THIS REAL
QUICK BEFORE YOU START I'VE JUST
GONNA TELL YOU OFF I APOLOGIZE.
IF YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS
RECOMMENDATIONS X. CENTER YOU
CAN GET THEM. TO DEBBIE LOOK IN
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
SHE'S LOOKING FOR YOUR EMAILS
AND YOUR COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS ON
THINGS -- I
MOSTLY AT ITS ITS WHAT'S WORKING.
WHAT WE SHOULD DO BUT ALSO THE
HOW HOW WE DO THIS WHAT WHAT
HURDLES ARE YOU ARE THERE OUT
THERE THAT ARE STOPPING YOU? FOR
THAT SOME IMPLEMENTING THESE
PROGRAMS AND MUCH SMOOTHER
FASHION THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO
DO.
ANOTHER CAN MANDATE THIS ALL
OVER THE STATE TODAY BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE
SOME HURDLES THAT MAYBE HAVE
BEEN CREATED OVER THERE WE CAN
SPIT IT OUT WITH THAT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHELLE CAPITA I'M
ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE
DIRECTOR FOR SCA YOU CALIFORNIA
SO I DON'T OFTEN MAKE AN
APPEARANCE IN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE --
BUT IS HE A YOU REPRESENTS BOTH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WORKERS
AS WELL AS CLASSIFIED SCHOOL
WORKERS WHO ARE THE NON
CERTIFIED STAFF AT SCHOOLS
INCLUDING BUS DRIVERS CAFETERIA
WORKERS AND COMMUNITY REPS
REALLY.
THEY'RE THE FOLKS WHO ARE SORT
OF IN THE BACKGROUND AT SCHOOLS
AND THEY CAN SERVE AS THE EYES
AND EARS AND SO ONE OF THE
POINTS THAT WE'D LIKE TO MAKE
TODAY'S THAT WE IN GENERAL
SHOULD BE.
LEVERAGING IN USING OUR EXISTING
RESOURCES BOTH ON CAMPUSES AS
WELL AS IN --
IN TERMS OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING TO DEVELOP THESE MODELS --
ARE CLASSIFIED WORKERS FOR
EXAMPLES KNOW WHEN KIDS DON'T
GET ENOUGH TO EAT THEY KNOW WHEN
THEY'RE WEARING THE SAME
CLOTHING DAY AFTER DAY AND
THEY'RE THERE TO OBSERVE AND
REALLY HELP SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
LIVES OF CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES --
WE AGREED THAT WE NEED TO DO A
BETTER JOB OF BRINGING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
CHILDREN ON CAMPUSES AND TO
THEIR FAMILIES AND THIS MEANS
BOTH MENTAL HEALTH AS WELL AS
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES --
SCA USE INTERESTED IN A
WRAPAROUND SERVICES APPROACH
WHICH INTEGRATES AS WE HEARD
TODAY FROM SEVERAL OF THE
EXAMPLES --
SOCIAL SERVICES AS WELL AS
SERVICES --
AND WE SUMMARIZE OKAY THANK YOU
WE HAVE COMMENTS ON THE CARVE
OUT QUESTION WHICH WAS RELEASED
EARLIER IN THE FINANCING BUT
OVERALL AS WE'RE DOING THIS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
SERVICES ARE HELD TO ITS MINIMUM
QUALITY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON RAIN BE SEEN WITH
THE NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS TIMELY HEARING ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC --
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY THAT WHEN IT
COMES A MENTAL HEALTH CALIFORNIA
FACES A CRISIS AND BASED ON THE
COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCE OF OUR
FOUR THOUSAND MEMBERS WHO WORK
AS MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE.
WE COMPLETELY AGREE --
CALIFORNIA'S CONSISTENTLY SAY
THAT THEIR COMMUNITY DOES NOT
HAVE ENOUGH MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS TO MEET THE LOCAL
NEEDS -- IN
ORDER TO ACTUALLY SUSPECTS THIS
IN THE SYSTEM IN A WAY FOR BOTH
CHILDREN AND ADULTS --
WE MUST IN CANCER STATES
PROVIDER NETWORK ADEQUACY
REQUIREMENTS STRENGTHENED TIMELY
ACCESS STANDARDS AND TAKE MORE
SUBSTANTIVE STEPS TO BETTER
IMPLEMENT THE MENTAL HEALTH
PARITY ACT ACROSS THE BOARD. ONE
EXAMPLE THE CHALLENGES WE FACE
KAISER IS THE STATE'S LARGEST
HMO WITH NINE MILLION ENROLLEES --
DO THE INADEQUACY OF ITS NETWORK
OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH PROVIDERS
MANY PATIENTS WAIT ONE TO TWO
MONTHS FOR APPOINTMENTS
INCLUDING THOSE WITH ACUTE
CONDITIONS.
THIS -- NOT
ONLY VIOLATES PROFESSIONALLY
RECOGNIZED STANDARDS BUT IT CAN
ALSO SUBSTANTIALLY PROLONG A
PATIENT'S RECOVERY TIMES.
THERE'S YOUNG GIRL THAT THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ON
THE HOUSE BY THE UNITED WAYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THIS HEARING IN
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
I ONE OF THE KEY ELEMENTS THAT I
HEARD IN THE CONVERSATION TODAY
WAS AROUND.
COLLABORATION CONNECTIONS ACROSS
SILOS IN BOLD SYSTEMS REFORM --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE
COMPLEX DISCUSSIONS AND BELIEVE
THE STATE HAS ACTUAL OPTIONS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN INCLUDING A
PROPOSAL TO RESTORE AND
MODERNIZE.
THE HEALTHY START INITIATIVE AT
SIMPLY PUT THE HEALTHY START --
INITIATIVE WOULD ESTABLISH CROSS
SERVICE COLLABORATIVE'S
SUPPORTED BY ROBUST TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ACT AS A LOCAL
FRAMEWORK TO ADDRESS THE MOST
PRESSING ISSUES FACING OUR YOUTH
AND FAMILIES TODAY --
AND I WILL BE SHARING.
ALONG WITH --
THE CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND --
SOME MORE BACKGROUND MATERIALS
TO YOUR STAFF.
ON THIS PROPOSAL --
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
AUTHORING A BILL SO THAT WILL
BECOME BEFORE THIS --
THIS COMMITTEE --
AND JUST TO KIND OF KEEP IT
SHORT A FRAMEWORK BOTH TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS THAT ARE
FACING CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
TODAY AROUND MENTAL HEALTH BUT
ALSO AS THE SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEM CHANGES FINANCING SYSTEMS
CHANGE.
OTHER NEEDS TO BE SUPPORT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO OPERATIONALIZE
THOSE CHANGES AND WE BELIEVE
HEALTHY START IS THE WAY FOR Và
THANK YOU --
CHAMPS COUNTY MATILDA'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA AND I JUST WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM UNITED WAY'S TO
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
HEALTHY START INITIATIVE AND
WILL BE BRINGING INFORMATION
ABOUT IT BUT I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT IT'S A DATA
DRIVEN PROGRAM THAT WE KNOW.
WORKS DRUG USE WENT DOWN AND
GRADUATION RATES WENT UP SO WE
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO TALKING
TO YOU MORE ABOUT THAT.
AND ALSO ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND HAS BEEN
SO INTERESTED IN IT IS THAT IT'S
AN INTEGRATED PROGRAM.
AND IT WAS THE CULMINATION OF
TWO YEARS OF RESEARCH LOOKING AT
PROGRAMS THAT WORK FOR CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND WE CAME TO THIS
CONCLUSION SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR
TO TALK.
ABOUT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS LINDA TENER
WHAT'S ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY DETECTION AND INTERVENTION
AS A MEANS OF PREVENTING LASTING
EFFECTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS SO AS FUNDS BECOME
AVAILABLE OUT THERE PROP SIXTY
FOUR CANNABIS REVENUES WE HOPE
THOSE DOLLARS CAN BE DRAWN TO
SUPPORT COST OF COST EFFECTIVE.
IN EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS AT
THE SCHOOL SITES --
SO THINGS LIKE A SPUR WHICH IS
THE SCREENING AND BRIEF
INTERVENTION AND REFERRAL TO
TREATMENT PROGRAM --
WE THINK THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS
REALLY INITIATE A DIALOGUE WITH
STUDENTS AND REALLY GET TO THE
HEART OF THEIR SUBSTANCE USE AND
REALLY SCREEN FOR THOSE RISK
FACTORS SO WE HOPE DOLLARS CAN
BE USED TO SUPPORT.
IN SCHOOL TREATMENT LIKE THAT --
AND HOPEFULLY CAN BECOME FULLY
FUNDED IN IT'S LASTLY I'D BE
REMISS IF WE DON'T DO NOT
ACKNOWLEDGE THE NEEDS OF OUR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT POPULATION
I KNOW DIDN'T GET CHANCE --
TO DIVE INTO THAT TOO MUCH TODAY --
BUT WE HOPE MOVING FORWARD THIS
BODY -- CAN
LOOK AT FUNDING STREAMS TO TO
SUPPORT THE SPECIFIC.
THANK WITH POPULATION YOUR OF
YOUR FIRST COMMENT ABOUT THE
WHERE THE MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS
GO.
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME OF THE THEM.
PROP SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS --
MISTER WOULD NIGHT WORKING ON
SOMETHING.
ALONG THOSE LINES TO MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT MONEY GOES. TO
DIFFERENT PLACES NOT JUST ONE
PLACE FANTASTIC THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THINKING.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEEP INDIGNATION
WITH THAT CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY --
ARE.
CALIFORNIA GRAHAM POLICY CENTER --
I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANT CHALLENGES THAT
CHILDREN IMMIGRANT FAMILIES FACE.
THE CHRONIC STRESS AND TRAUMA
THAT THEY DO RECEIVE BY SEEING A
PARENT DEPORTED OR ARRESTED --
THESE TO THESE ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES --
ADD UP AND RESULT IN SOME.
REALLY BAD OUTCOMES WHEN IT
COMES TO SCHOOL.
IN A RECENT SURVEY THAT WE DID
OF CALIFORNIA THE MAJORITY OF
NOTED THAT THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE
IN THEIR CHILD'S BEHAVIOR --
BUT THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED AND WE THINK
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE INCREASED
TRAINING TO DEAL WITH I YOU KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH IMMIGRANT
FAMILIES AND CULTURE COMMUNITIES.
ARE AND LANGUAGE ACCESS --
TO HELP STUDENTS IN SCHOOL
SETTINGS ON WHERE THEY DO TRUST
THE PROVIDERS --
WE ALSO THINK THAT IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
CHILDREN DO HAVE MEDICAL
COVERAGE EVEN IF THEY'RE
UNDOCUMENTED.
BUT IT IS REALLY CRITICAL TO
EXTEND MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY TO
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS AS WELL
BECAUSE WHEN THE PARENTS DR --
IT'S MORE LIKELY THAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING
HEALTHCARE ACCESS THANK YOU SO
MUCH THEIR BEST ROBUST
DISCUSSION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHRIS
MILLER I'M A DOCTOR CAN AND
EDUCATION AT THE RICHEST IMAGE
CISCO REALLY SHOULD BE AT HOME
WORKING ON MY DISSERTATION.
IT'LL BE WAITING FOR ME WHEN I
GET HOME BACK TO MY HOMETOWN OF
LOS GATOS AND SILICON VALLEY.
I WAS A POINT IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN BY THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TO THE STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH POLICY WORK GROUP.
AN EFFORT OF THE CD EAT THAT
ASSESSES THE CURRENT MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS.
AND GATHER EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT
ITS POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE.
I AM ALSO SERVING ON THE HEALTH
COLLABORATION COMMITTEE WHICH
WILL FOCUS ON THE ROLLOUT OF THE
HEALTH FRAMEWORK ONCE ADOPTED BY
THE STATE BOARD OF ED IN MAY.
INFORMED OF AFTERNOON THANK YOU
TO THE PANELISTS FOR THEIR
INSIGHTS AND WISDOM.
AS WE HEARD TODAY GOOD MENTAL
HEALTH OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
NOW WHAT CAN THE COMMITTEE DUE
TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH.
WELLNESS LIKE TO PROPOSE THAT
THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER POSSIBLE
LEGISLATION HEALTH AND SUICIDE
PREVENTION INSTRUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS SENATE BILL
THREE SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR IN.
TWENTY THIRTEEN SUGGESTS THAT
THE I. Q. C. CONSIDER ADDING
MENTAL HEALTH INSTRUCTION THE
WHOLE FREE MARK.
WELL THAT'S ALL IN GOOD THE FACT
IS IN MANY SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
THERE IS NO SUCH HEALTH CLASS.
SO I AM WORKING WITH A FEW
LEGISLATORS ON THE IDEA.
LEGISLATION CAN BE MODELED ON
WHAT WAS RECENTLY APPROVED IN
THE STATES OF NEW YORK AND
VIRGINIA IS THE LAST SIX MONTHS
WHICH YOU HAVE --
IT CALIFORNIA'S ALWAYS BEEN THE
FOREFRONT OF INNOVATIVE POLICIES
IN LOSS IN OUR SCHOOLS WHAT
BETTER WAY TO SUPPORT WAS
REITERATED ABOUT THANK YOU FOR
MENTAL HEALTH EDUCATION
AFTERNOON THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE DEARBORN REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES I THINK
ALL OF US AWARE THAT THE SCHOOL
NURSES ON THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL IN SCHOOL.
AND THEY ARE THE DETECTIVE THAT
VERY EARLY ON CAN ADD A DELTA
PHI MANY OF THE CHILDREN THAT
HAVE ISSUES AND SCHOOLS.
THE SCHOOL NURSE OFFICE IS SEEN
AS A SAFE HAVEN AND WE SPEND
ABOUT 32% OF ALL TIME ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE SCHOOL HEALTH ISSUES --
WE AGREE WITH YOU THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A TEAM OR A SYSTEMS
APPROACH. TO DEALING WITH ALL
THESE ISSUES THE CHILDREN BRING
TO SCHOOL BOTH PHYSICAL PHYSICAL
AND EMOTIONAL AND TO THAT END.
WE ARE SUPPORTING AND LIKELY TO
BE INTRODUCING A BILL THAT HAS
TO DO WITH THE OFFICE OF SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH.
WHICH WILL SET UP A
COLLABORATIVE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
WE BELIEVE WITH THAT
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH WE WE
WILL BE ABLE TO MAXIMIZE THE
ONLY A MOP BILLING.
FUNDING THAT COMES INTO THE
STATE. SIX THANK YOU COMMITTEE
ADRIAN SHELTON WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE JUST REALLY
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
TODAY AND THE AND THE STAFF OF
PUTTING TOGETHER SUCH A DYNAMIC
HEARING --
REALLY GREAT TO BE A PART OF
THIS.
THERE'S REALLY NO QUESTION BASED
ON THE RESEARCH AND DATA
PRESENTED TODAY THAT WE HAVE A
CRISIS WHEN IT COMES TO YOU THE
ADOLESCENT MENTAL HEALTH.
BUT I THINK THE QUESTION ON THE
TABLE IS WHAT ROLE DO THE
SCHOOLS PLAY.
AND GIVEN ALL OF THEIR OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES --
CAN THEY TAKE ON MENTAL HEALTH
AND THESE ARE REALLY --
LEGITIMATE QUESTIONS OF THE
PROFESSIONALS HERE.
ARE GRAPPLING WITH ON A DAILY
BASIS AND WE REALLY FEEL THAT
SCHOOLS PLAY A CENTRAL ROLE IN
THE MENTAL HEALTH --
I'VE OF STUDENTS AND THERE WAS A
MODEL THAT WAS TALKED ABOUT
QUITE A BIT TODAY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND HOW THEY FOR THE PAST
TWO DECADES HAVE HAVE PARTNERED
WITH THEIR CENTER FOR HEALTHY
SCHOOLS TO ESTABLISH --
INTEGRATED MENTAL HEALTH AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH ON CAMPUS
SERVICES AND THEY PARTNER WITH
THE COMMUNITY TO BRING AND
SPECIALIZED --
YOU KNOW STAFF TRAINED --
TO DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES OF THE YOUTH AND WE
REALLY FEEL LIKE THIS COULD BE A
MODEL THAT COULD BE SCALED UP
ACROSS THE STATE.
SO -- LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH THE
COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHELLE TO
STIR AND I'M A NATIONALLY
CERTIFIED SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGIST
WHO HAS WORKED IN FOUR STATES
ACROSS NUMEROUS SCHOOL SYSTEMS
INCLUDING ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND PARTIAL
HOSPITALIZATION PROGRAMS.
I AM ALSO A PARENT OF A CHILD
WHO HAS MENTAL ILLNESS.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND DEVELOPING
LEGISLATION REGARDING THREAT
ASSESSMENTS AND INTERVENTION AND
DATA COLLECTION WITHIN OUR K. TO
TWELVE SCHOOLS.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO STATES
WHO HAVE PASSED LAST LAWS
REGARDING SCHOOL THREAT
ASSESSMENTS THESE STATES ARE
VIRGINIA AND FLORIDA.
I THINK OUR SCHOOLS DESERVE
THESE PROTECTIONS BEFORE THE
NEXT HEINOUS ACT I BRING THIS
YEAR ATTENTION AS SOMEONE WHO IS
WORKING IN YOUR SCHOOLS AND SEES
A VERY REAL NEED FOR MANDATES
NOT GUIDELINES WHICH COMPELS
SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO HAVE WELL
DEVELOPED PROTOCOLS.
IN PLACE FOR DOCUMENTING
ASSESSING AND PROVIDING
INTERVENTIONS FOR SOME OF OUR
MOST AT RISK YOUTH.
HOW MUCH TIME DO I HAVE --
STUDIES SHOW THAT SCHOOLS WHICH
UTILIZE FORMALIZED DREADED
SUSSMAN'S AS PART OF THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO SCHOOL
SAFETY HAVE STUDENTS TO REPORT
LESS BULLYING A GREATER
WILLINGNESS TO SEEK OUT HELP
FROM ADULTS.
MORE POSITIVE PERCEPTIONS OF
THEIR SCHOOL CLIMATE AND
REDUCTIONS OF RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN SCHOOL DISCIPLINE I KNOW THE
POSITIVE IMPACT BECAUSE I HAVE
DONE THIS AND AND THE STATE OF
MARYLAND OUTSIDE OF BALTIMORE
AND I'D LIKE TO SEE IT HAPPEN
AND TELLING HIM.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HI WON'T.
HI MY NAME IS STEPHANIE WONG I
AM A SENIOR AT OAK RIDGE HIGH
SCHOOL AND I'M ALSO THE FOUNDER
OF THE MOUNTAIN MENTAL HEALTH
MENTAL WELLNESS FUND OF THE AUTO
TO COMMUNITY FOUNDATION --
RECENTLY WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH --
CALIFORNIA NORTH STATE
UNIVERSITY'S SCHOOL OF
PSYCHOLOGY OF WHO HAVE PROPOSED
A PRACTICUM SITE.
A MY SCHOOL DISTRICT TO SEND
THEIR PHD STUDENTS TO STATION AT
OUR SCHOOLS AND HELP --
COUNCIL AND ALSO TRAIN TEACHERS
AND STUDENTS ALIKE WE A WE
BELIEVE AFTER NUMEROUS MEETINGS
OF THE PRACTICUM PROGRAM IS
OFFICIALLY ESTABLISHED.
AND IT WILL BE IT WILL START
WORKING IN THE SUMMER AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL BE A VERY
GOOD MODEL.
FOR FUTURE --
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO FOLLOW
AS A TEMPORARY OR TO FIND A MORE
PERMANENT.
THE IDEAS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO O'DONNELL
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING --
CHRIS STONER MERTZ FORMERLY THE
CEO OF LINK AND ONE OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MISTER
BRISCOE REFERENCE.
THAT'S DOING OF SCHOOL BASED
MENTAL HEALTH IN TWO COUNTIES
ALAMEDA ENCOUNTER ACOSTA SERVING
ABOUT FIFTY DIFFERENT SCHOOLS.
ACROSS THIS COUNTIES --
I'M ALSO NOW TAKING ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ROLE AT THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE.
OF CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES.
THAT IS A HUNDRED AND FORTY
PROVIDERS DOING THIS WORK AS
WELL.
WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
ATTENTION THAT'S BEING BROUGHT
TODAY WE HAVE THERE IS EXPERTISE
IN THE CBO COMMUNITY TO REALLY.
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR KIDS AND
SUPPORT THOSE SCHOOLS WE ARE
EXPERTS IN PROVIDING THE MEDI
CAL SERVICES AND UNDERSTANDING
HOW TO BREED AND BLEND FUNDING.
AND I I WANT TO ECHO WHAT MANY
OF THE YEAR THE SPEAKER SAID
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF MULTI
TIERED SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT SO
THAT WE'RE NOT JUST FOCUSED ON A
PST TEA BUT ALSO.
REALLY FINDING AN ADDITIONAL
WAYS.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT ME INTO A READ
ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
COUNSELORS.
AND NUMBER OF COUNTY OFFICES
INCLUDING SANTA CLARA SAN DIEGO
BUTTE -- AND
THE THREE EXTRA REPRESENTATIVES
YOU HAD TODAY FROM PLASTER
MONTEREY AND HUMBLE.
SO APPRECIATED HEARING THIS IS
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE HERE OUT
FROM OUR SCHOOLS I WOULD SAY
THAT WHILE --
SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT WE DON'T
WANT HAVE EDUCATORS TRYING TO
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH WE DON'T
WANT MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
TRYING TO PROVIDE EDUCATION SO
IT HAS TO BE A PARTNERSHIP --
AND WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THE COMMITTEE ARE ARE
GREAT COLLEAGUES A SCHOOL NURSES
TO TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MORE WASCO WITH THE
BALL FROST GROUP AND ALSO
REPRESENTING ORANGE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WE WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE IN THE PANEL
MEMBERS FOR HIGHLIGHTING.
THE MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT WE BELIEVE MTS US IS A
GOOD FOUNDATION.
FOR ADDRESSING THE STARTING TO
ADDRESS THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF OUR STUDENTS WOULD ALSO LIKE --
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS REGARDING
REFORMING OUR MEDICARE PROGRAM
AND MORE SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT
U. P. S. D. T. AND WHO CAN DRAW
DOWN THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M FAIR
IMITATING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES WE REPRESENT THE COUNTY
SUPERVISORS FROM ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES.
JUST A SHORT COMMENT THAT WE
LOOK FOR TO PARTNERING WITH
SCHOOLS AND FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
PARTNER I THINK THERE ARE SOME
GREAT IDEAS HERE TODAY.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
IN THE WORK ON THIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU --
WILL THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY THANK THOSE
WHO SPOKE FOR ALSO SHOWED UP TO
HEAR LISTEN AND AND THANK YOU
DEBBIE LOOK FOR PUTTING TOGETHER
IS HEARING.
PUTTING TODAY'S HEARING TOGETHER.
AND I MISTER KILEY --
FOR SAYING HEY WE NEED TO WE
NEED TO EXPLORE THIS TOPIC AND
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT DISCUSSION
ABOUT IT WITH THAT THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.
THANKS PATRICK THANK YOU DEBBIE